- five four three three - yeah with live
ladies and gentlemen thousand episodes
Tom Segura Joey [ __ ] Diaz we're
delayed in starting ladies and gentlemen
we did not have a lighter that was a
real panic setting that's embarrassing
yeah I thought I thought some [ __ ] was
really gonna go down but thank God I am
petrified of earthquakes and situations
I don't put slippers on
I sleep with sneakers on store water
water tools yeah I got two weapons in an
ar-15 you've been out here for an
earthquake one of them that didn't scare
me yeah but I was just sitting by the
computer knows looking at the cat bowls
yeah yeah you get on I was gonna cats I
was one of the cat bowls and all son the
whole building tip I saw the cat balls
up in the air spinning and the cats
running for their lives they acted they
were acting we have a couple seconds
before that and that's why I go why they
so [ __ ] up oh they were acting weird
before the earth they say yeah that
they're doing that awesome dog I just
saw the cat balls it's like a cartoon up
in the air spinning the earthquake and
the whole building shifted I heard the
bricks the whole thing I thought about
it being at night sleep apnea you gotta
have a conveyor well that [ __ ] and
they suck they sound like for 600 you
get one with everything lights an iron
it [ __ ] cleans your water the
scariest [ __ ] when you [ __ ] you panic
about what earthquakes are likely if you
before you move here you know and then
you I remember the first week I was here
I was in an apartment in Sherman Oaks
and I was standing at the kitchen
counter of this person's apartment on
their laptop doing like sending an email
and I felt a little and I go in my head
I go I ask the subway and I kept typing
and then he could you feel that and I
was like yeah he's like crazy right
that's the earth shake underneath your
feet and I was like oh it's like a panic
sets in you're like
oh my god I've actually experienced the
earth moving now and then the next step
is like when you are you don't you like
if you're asleep and then you hear like
you feel the dresser but you hear the
dresser you know or or something that's
hanging on your wall bumping you know
what the [ __ ] going on takes you that
extra beat to figure out they were going
through an earthquake that extra B is
[ __ ] it's obvious you've been through
nothing big
but like fives 5.5 s a couple of years
the first one I was in was an aftershock
of the Northridge earthquake I was
staying in North Hollywood and I was in
this shitty apartment it was made out of
like [ __ ] the same boxes that they
used like the ship refrigerators and
like literally the walls when the
earthquake hit the walls are swelling
this I mean like the whole thing was
just like a giant was pushing on the
scariest [ __ ] right yeah well it's
humbling yeah
cuz you realize like this is nothing
this isn't it turning up the street this
isn't knocking over any houses imagine
what it felt like when that big one hit
and it hit for 30 seconds yeah 30 30
seconds is so long to feel the ground
moving that's why those people moved to
Boulder well that's what I was just
gonna say that when you had that
experience there's some people that
because for a few days after the
Northridge there was aftershocks yeah
and there's people that one day look at
that kids and go I'm not going through
this again you're working we'll [ __ ]
yeah working will Shire yeah big
building what if Thousand Oaks yeah so a
lot of people just a bad that's what
everybody's waiting for an earthquake
here because then people leave when they
sell their houses for dirt cheap what
the world does happen we're out we're
gone they don't ever want to experience
it again but then I see a guy like my
uncle's lived here since 55 and I've
asked him will you know you feel but
dude when I first moved here before I
first moved here I was out here for
meetings and I went by a section of the
highway I think it was the ten that had
collapsed and they were moving cars
around it yeah and as we're is this what
happened what is this an apartment
building that collapsed I just North
Quay oh this is the Northridge one yeah
dude that was a [ __ ] serious
earthquake man yeah like [ __ ]
and when I was driving by this one
section of the highway it collapsed on
the lower section and I remember
thinking that's just [ __ ] luck like this
right here yeah yeah like you could be
there and that is just [ __ ] lot is
really
blam that thing lands on you and that's
how you go that's I'm sorry I am a
hard-working individual I really try to
do anything I could to help myself
but when people call me well tell me
they want me to go to a meeting and
Santa Monica after like three unless I'm
picking up an envelope I tell him well
that kids won the Oscar from Modern
Family and he said I was always the guy
that went to Ocean Avenue at five for
those auditions yeah you deserve an
Oscar because you gotta wait on that
ramp in the middle of that yeah
your mind starts playing I'm telling you
I've been stuck on that ramp and I'm
gone never again
oh man I want to go through this ramp I
don't ever want to be in the middle of
that ramp that's not good not good your
mind starts playing with you and you
remember that those images and you go
[ __ ] that okay let me pull let's plan
this right now if the [ __ ] hits the fan
this thing shakes to the ground yeah
where are we going
cuz listen one of the main reasons why I
like being in LA is because I like you
guys yes what we're gonna all go like I
like for real like a hundred percent
like that that was the thing that
bothered me the most about Colorado I
there was a lot of nice people out there
but I didn't know you you guys weren't
out there alone
it's a lot I see when we work together
on the but there's something fun about
running in you guys all the time yeah
like it makes life better we do sense a
store a factory and wherever we're at
it's more fun
it makes life more fun I would do this
podcast a hundred percent how do you
move to Colorado yeah that's what I'm
talking about that state that's what we
do there goes the right way you gotta
remember guys it's not our decision in
that it could be you call mrs. Rogan sit
you down and go that's it I'm not living
yes again yeah yeah that's what that's
how and I'm in fact I packed the bags
without you I'm go to a hotel like what
effects that way
but they don't like this ends right
today yeah with that with that
earthquake yeah if you feel it if you
feel that [ __ ] the ones that
take down highways if you feel that you
like oh my god again this is not even a
really big one
yeah really big ones change the shape of
continents true I mean that's the real
fear the real fear is there's a giant
one like a ten or an eleven part of you
by the way always feels kind of crazy
like when I was growing up and Florida
up with hurricanes that like after a
hurricane you're like are we staying
yeah yeah but there's something about a
hurricane like for whatever reason I
feel like if you're just in the basement
the top blows off the thing and you just
[ __ ] strap you're sometimes like a
wild ride at Disneyland but but now they
give you these warnings they're like
you're definitely gonna die and people
still are like bucket yeah for sure my
friend's mom his mom is like 70
something years old and this big one was
coming they're like this time we're not
[ __ ] around this is a category five
this is going to absolutely devastate
this area and she was like absolutely
not I've been here 40 some years
nothing ever [ __ ] happens and he
begged her and she was like no and it's
like you know those are always those
reports are always rolling the dice cuz
they they'll say it's gonna be this bad
and then it'll you know it'll turn or
tool and different yeah and it turned
into like a tropical storm she was like
see but she was like the only person
that stayed like everybody else we would
always bail I don't know if you were
ever there for hurricane no but like we
would always book it man as soon as they
were like this thing is gonna land we're
like no there's no way and the even
driving in those tropical storms was
unreal men like you can't see an inch in
front of the car it's like you're
driving through a carwash
we had a stop once were you with me when
Eddie did that seminar in Miami well we
were working at West Palm did you go
down with us no we went wee Eddie's
doing a seminar in West Palm or in Miami
we have in West Palm it's like a half
hour way so we left to go to the seminar
and we were stopped dead on the highway
you could not see an inch in front of
the windshield it's amazing it was
[ __ ] crazy
it lasted for about 15 minutes but it
was just the time there all the time we
don't even know what rain is no we don't
even know and I never knew growing up
like in Boston growing up growing up in
Boston I never saw that yeah we saw it
rain we never saw that I got some
next-level I haven't really seen it
duplicated since leaving the crowd as a
child I saw one bad rainstorm in Jersey
where the clouds got dark yeah it
started hailing have you ever lived
through Hamlin yeah oh that's Jesse
videos of what people's cars are just
going to surround it yeah and there's
one dude one guy had a film of a lake
they were watching it and it slowly
ramps up it's like one yeah one two and
he's like whoa look at the size of this
hail and then all suddenly it's fun it's
literally being attacked with rocks from
space
look at this yeah there's a gang of
these man but like look at this one it
[ __ ] people's toys destroys power that
was happening dude a thousand roofers
moved to Colorado because there's work
for two [ __ ] years yeah you get
Kansas Christ yeah look at it's getting
worse
this is insane dude you get K owed okay
especially if you're like a little kid
Oh actually being a five-year-old out in
this you know [ __ ] pummeled to death
has anybody ever died from hail perhaps
has to heaven seems like it the first
week I'm segura the first week I moved
to LA on a Monday and that Friday was
the North Hollywood shootout I was
living with staying home yeah I went to
find the job that Friday yeah there was
a bunch of traffic and they were like
that is North Hollywood shoot that that
shootout changed policing nationwide you
know that that incident changed the way
they viewed
having weapons changed their training
they've never even competent like
contemplated that people have robbed a
bank with like fully automatic your
shoes
see coming out with the body armor
talking boy ms2 was laying by a car
after he was hit - shooting up at
helicopters and [ __ ] that was [ __ ]
crazy man
I remember that national news that was
just like a big you couldn't get on the
101 now you I was in the news radio
break room
we were we were getting ready to film a
scene and we were watching it me and
kandi Alexander huddled up together
going what the [ __ ] everybody came in
guys get in here get in here but we're
all in there watching like what in the
[ __ ] and it changed the way they what
kind of tactics they use and the
equipment they give police absolutely
like they had 38 SPAC then they still
reference it all the time yeah I did a
ride-along two months ago with the
Hollywood division dude and I was a guy
was still talking about it's like we
have this because of this shootout and
you know that's a lot of people say oh
man [ __ ] the militarization of the
police man this is what and there's a
lot of it that's not good you give to
people too much power it's not good yeah
but if some [ __ ] happens like that they
need that otherwise they're sitting
ducks yeah you know kind of weapons you
get on the streets right now
Oh crazy a firepower you get on the
streets from a ar-15 you get some wild
[ __ ] out of the [ __ ] straw all you
have to do is this number it's real
quick mathematics for anybody's
interested there's 350 million people
somewhere around this country there's
more guns and there are people and
they're still making guns every day they
make guns there's a gun making industry
it's gigantic yeah they're making all
kinds of guns all over the country right
every year like every other make more
high-tech they're not getting rid of any
guns no no all those guns for toys Oh
give back your gun and you'll get a toy
okay
lose yourself someone's a factory going
on right now they're cranking out a are
some rusty old 22 [ __ ] handball court
you get anything except like hunting
rifle I can't believe they're playing
handball still that's dedicated to
handball who's like I'm gonna be the
better prison so when you get
and disability you play handball then
it's a cover for you that you're half a
moment when you play hammer so guns that
kill you'll get a gun at a handball
court for $50 that shot three people
that gun has a Miss a [ __ ] shot
him so a [ __ ] committed suicide
long range with those guys [ __ ] they got
guns that don't miss on the web handball
courts did you play you play handball in
prison asia i played handball like the
first two weeks and it just wasn't for
me
you ran in colorado in because there was
a few guys in the bronx yeah so when I
went to Summit County cuz I was arrested
in Boulder but once you start your state
sentence they were gonna send me to the
Missouri of Texas I ended up going to
Summit County Summit County is like we
don't really have boys yeah oh no you
just do what you want here yeah at night
at 10 o'clock the guard would go to
Pathmark
that Pathmark like a supermarket yeah
and get his chips and soda what it was
like a [ __ ] daycare Wow
get along Pete everyone got along pretty
well yeah yeah yeah I'm not what a dude
from the Bronx that played handball we
became friends together he had been on
the run for 12 years but this guy was
brilliant he was [ __ ] brilliant like
this [ __ ] he had done he had driven the
cops we're like what's that movie Lee
allowed to Caprio catch me if you can
that he was that good right and the
final thing he did for them was they
caught him he set him up on the drugs
thing like I read the paperwork it was
brilliant he sent him up on the drug
drugs then he said I know why he'd go by
10 kilos of coke the cops actually gave
$250,000 cash to buy the ten kilos of
coke
he set it up with his friend to have a
car behind the house the car was empty
the house was empty there was no cops
never even did a background check to see
who lived in the house Jesus the house
is empty he went through the front and
1/2 the back and disappeared travel for
ten years and he came back to the states
because his dad died they arrested why
years ago he went for like Aruba and
just played shuffleboard handball that's
a dark world the world of the expat no
South American tourist communities yeah
that's like that
sizable too right sighs yeah all over
Mexico there's a lot of people in Brazil
I have friends in South America that's
dad was a island hopping all throughout
his adolescence just to avoid taxes just
to avoid taxes Wow
and then the crazy thing to me is that
is that they came here like they came
back eventually and like so is he in
trouble he's like no how is he not in
trouble he's like I don't know aren't
they gonna catch him he's like what do
you mean man like he's here now like is
a whole new identity no okay don't worry
busy busy pay taxes he says he know and
he's like oh he doesn't she still
doesn't but and then my friend was still
like you know you don't have to pay
taxes yeah I know he goes he goes google
it yeah you have to pay taxes that's
your thing like just look it up man
goddammit pay your taxes of course it
doesn't matter if you pay them see if
you owe money to say like Exxon you know
whatever they'll sue you you have to pay
the money and pay the money but if the
IRS if you owe money to the IRS they put
you in a [ __ ] cage for sure guard
'less of if you pay whoa whoa whoa let's
say even if you don't even if you agree
to pay it yeah yeah you're gonna go in
cage first yeah no you pay well a
company money they file a judgment
against you and they sell the paper and
then you can called a comedy clubs like
I used to you know when I first started
calmly I owed so much money did you
really I go to a comedy club the manager
who just got a call just got to recall
and I go holy [ __ ] it's HBO really mine
that would go to HBO
oh [ __ ] Gojo it's the same guy and I'd
pick up the phone Joey a Discover Card
we never got that payment [ __ ]
why he [ __ ] figured out they have
tremendous scams two people looking for
you yeah
they have a computer that they'll go on
to see what other numbers that usually
call you and now get that number when
they call you that number will come up
over your caller ID they do some illegal
[ __ ] mmm when they're looking for you
but when you get a judgment from Exxon
seven years you don't pay it it goes
away
government that judgment never goes away
that and the student alone
these [ __ ] that tell student
loans to suck their dick oh yeah student
loans even more intense oh yeah yeah
well you know that's all the government
as well that's right the thing about
student loans is it doesn't get erased
when you go to bankruptcy
yeah it doesn't file for bankruptcy
anything else is gone you know yeah I
pay the student loan I thought it was
cute I took the last one out the 2625
the minimum [ __ ] you
I've known a couple of people they
showed up about three years ago dog with
a big ol number I had to get an attorney
gonna go she ate it down and get off it
oh the IRS I didn't pay taxes from
ninety after 2001 what dog that was
crazy
I was hiding I was doing you know was
that making eight thousand years a road
comic yeah I got a file yeah so I didn't
file I made money one out of the 13
years 111 years and one day I walked in
downtown downtown I thought they were
gonna shoot me in the head
mm-hmm I took a number they called my
name I went back to I told my hadn't
father in 11 years they asked me what I
did I talked to the lady for a half hour
she she goes we don't go back for seven
so you've got seven three years no they
don't draw you in both listen you have
to be a dumb [ __ ] for them to
throw you in jail or you have to be a
public figure they give you every option
John the public figures you're actually
worse off then if you're some just
legitimate businessman if you're a
public figure I could go down there with
my attorney and say look yeah I'm gonna
shoot ten movies and the next no they
wouldn't they would not let Wesley
Snipes do that because if he gave him
such a at first he was telling them all
this [ __ ] that [ __ ] rules and [ __ ] do
you think he was just the man he was
talking about all that [ __ ] and that
[ __ ] drives him crazy
I don't think he was made a case that he
didn't owe them yes and they'll play
with you once you start talking about
amendment 11 right Thomas Jefferson
reparations
napkins eyes I don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
those people out there that convince
people that they don't have to pay taxes
and it's not in the Constitution it's
like they want to believe it like a
conspiracy theory you know no it might
be here's the thing I mean it you might
have a legal argument but it doesn't
matter they'll put you in a [ __ ] cage
tax evasion take that money and put you
in a [ __ ] cage mama getting my kid
from [ __ ] the solution what's that
that kid that what happened to him he
tried to preside he actually didn't just
not pay his taxes there was some
shenanigans he made less than he
actually did go get you why these Pete
roses and they got Sinbad remember that
they were putting my page LA Times for
years you know Mike the situation so
disco more charges yet including tax
evasion and structuring yes acts evasion
like once you structure it and you're
the mastermind part of the story was to
me that for that period that they're
like hitting him up about he made nine
million dollars so no I just was amazed
that like from the I didn't realize that
from I mean I remember that show
obviously a huge hit but that's
incredible sum of money we should really
pay attention to this like not just his
but what what they can do cuz you think
about what it is is we're just talking
about money right and we're talking
about some deception on his part that
yeah where you try to keep some money
yeah try to make it look like it was
anybody else yeah save yeah you're in
some sort of a deal with Costco and you
do some sneaky [ __ ] and decide they they
can sue you and you owe them and you
have to pay them but there's no threat
of jail time right right I mean is there
if you tried to like cook the books well
they can yes what they put you in jail
would they just trying wire fraud they
have a glove probably fine so I'm
guessing right the same kind of scrutiny
and attention though that he's getting
no I think it'd be about all about
paying a lot of money let's let's put
let's pretend that Mike Sorrentino is
that his name let's pretend that he had
some sort of a deal
Chevrolet and you know he was using his
name to sell cars but he was [ __ ]
around with some money and cooking the
books and a little bit of this a little
bit of that to the same tune as what was
going on with the IRS what do you think
they would do to him wouldn't would you
even be seeing this on TV no they would
know there'd be like a suit right
because what they're saying is this guy
tried to [ __ ] the Big Daddy right I mean
that's what they're showing you showing
you that Big Daddy gets mad when you try
to [ __ ] him and in the grand scheme of
things like it's a lot of money to her
individually to earn but it's you know
it's not up money that affects Big Daddy
maybe setting up she's coming after you
but here's the strange thing Big Daddy
is just people like what why do we let
anything be Big Daddy yeah like the I we
used to think of it I think from like
almost like a primitive perspective like
you have a king you know or you have a
leader of a tribe yeah I think that's
that's how people used to think of it
and used to think of all these
organizations whether it's the FBI or
the DEA as being a part of that but
there are just a bunch of [ __ ] people
yeah and no person should ever be Big
Daddy to the point where if you have
money that's owed to someone else
perhaps and there's some sort of an
argument that you've been deceptive that
they can just swoop down and take all
your money like they lock it all up like
they go no no no no we're [ __ ]
freezing your funds like you didn't
Exxon doesn't get to do that yeah Chevy
doesn't get to do that other
corporations don't get to that but Big
Daddy has the overall say if you violate
Big Daddy's code even though Big Daddy
like you don't eat you don't need to get
a receipt from from Big Daddy you give
Big Daddy half your money and Big Daddy
just takes in spends and you know you
said what you don't think you should pay
taxes you [ __ ] hippie what are you a
Bernie Sanders supporter not even saying
that now you can saying that I think
don't you think Big Daddy should be
accountable if Big Daddy's gonna be able
to just throw us in a cage because we
don't give him ones and zeroes don't
think Big Daddy should be a little bit
accountable just be way more accountable
for their spending way more
or you shouldn't just you should be able
to check off boxes - yeah it should be
like like needs like health care check
like police department check fire
department check things of you we all
like to have to pay yeah and then there
should be elective things a bunch of
elective [ __ ] you know well I feel like
they should also like our
representatives should be way more
willing and like act like mandated to
explain in detail and like what they're
doing what they're spending on yeah and
I feel like a lot of you know house
represent Congress Senate there's just
like an air of arrogance about the way
that they even handle them you know I
mean they have power of course they're
big daddy they're big daddy and like
it's yeah I mean it's the just like
aloofness that they have is like you
always been upsetting them it's [ __ ]
gross no one should be big daddy and you
debt I mean the the people in Congress
should be humble and they you know
that's one of the things about Obama say
what you want about Obama were the
electus policies as a human being that
guy conducted himself better than any
president ever the way he spoke the way
he interacted with people the way he
even responded criticism you know we're
not just talking about its policy yeah
you might hate the class portable chair
yeah as good as it's ever been
yeah which is why this Trump ting is in
such direct contrast when he's yelling
the other day it's some reporter and he
said you know your fake news he used
that again man he said be quiet fake
news or something like that what he's
talking about something you know we can
like conflate the two like if you want
to take talk about policy and
effectiveness of an administration and
just personal conduct like let's say you
take all the politics out of it
that's what while there's a lot of
people to this moment still yeah if you
just even separate politics which a lot
of people are in favor of just the way
he conducts himself some people love it
listen let's be honest it's very very
small amount of people love it right but
a lot yeah you know you were saying
before there's no debtors prison yeah
there's no debtors prison when I first
got in Takami I was getting divorced I
was getting squeezed by an attorney and
as much as I never forget the first day
I miss
a payment for anything like I'll never
forget how terrible right yeah that my
credit rating everything I had worth all
those years we had one down the toilet
and then at that point I said if I'm
walking on ice I might as well dance I
mean I was just buying cars and [ __ ]
around and you know what they couldn't
throw me in jail for all that [ __ ] but
one not discover closed my account yeah
and I went home and opened up my drawing
one of those clothes with you when you
want coke you get [ __ ] Einstein you
get creative jack I went home and I hope
and let her draw and I saw those checks
of those three checks that this cover
sends you yeah when you first went to
card and kept the card I had a bank
account back a bold or whatever was
called I had my bat my car financed
through that I went in there that a
24-hour drive-through I wouldn't have
one o'clock and sign that check over to
myself for a thousand I waited for two
seconds and also an envelope came out
with a hundred with ten hundreds I'd
peeled them to ninety out of the hem one
day and not no one had ever called and
said you got an hour to bring that
[ __ ] money back we're gonna charge
you with fraud ooh and I was put up
against the thing I went to the bank I
told me was a mistake I didn't know and
one lady said you know what I'll take
that thousand I'll give you the thousand
but I'm gonna put it into your car loan
and raise the payments by twenty five
bucks for every thousand is twenty five
bucks and that's the only reason why
they go to jail for that [ __ ] thing
so they don't put you in jail for being
in debt they put you in jail for
deception
you know how they get athletes and
entertainers you know what that biggest
downfall is when they go to Comic Cons
and those autograph signings oh they
don't they don't get paid for those but
they get paid for those don't report
there's two things there's the people
who get $5,000 flat mm-hmm and you take
pictures all day then there's the people
that get ten dollars for their t-shirt
and $15 for a headshot and a smile yeah
those fifteen dollars go in your pocket
bro I'm sorry and what happens is you
have to give a percentage the fifteen
dollars to the guy it's like when you
sell merch at a comedy club now all of a
sudden not a one eight percent a emerge
well that guy reports it but Pete Rose
or than just saying
Piero's I'm not against yes roses my dog
Pete Rose he just puts 15 dollars in his
pocket right
what $60 war he took 10 pictures it
sonjin $50 that's how they they come get
you and all those autograph things right
what you wanna hear
what's this is from an article that's
two ladies talking about mmm
this article is talking about walking
away from comic-con with garbage bags
full of 20s this guy said he can make up
to 250 grand wide [ __ ] twice they didn't
feel a need for representation because
he's walking out with a bag full of cash
what who is he it's like a unnamed
Persis a source deeply involved steven
arnelle who became so enhanced the
festival business that he started zone
talent agency the star of the era of the
show the arrow oh wow that's a lot of
money yeah that seems very strange
comic-con you pay for a booth and then I
think you give them three percent of
your overall take don't you think that's
really bizarre having people paid to
come and meet you
that seems real strange I think it's
weird to charge somebody for a picture
and then charge somebody to sign I mean
I guess the signing thing I understand
there's a bit especially in sports you
know they're selling a book but are
these your thing that you're signing oh
five hundred thousand dollars a weekend
who the [ __ ] gets that guy from the
walking dead Norman Reedus what owe
$200,000 guarantee back guarantee it
okay five hundred grand a weekend I love
celebrities who get a flat and the ones
that on the way real low like if you
want Lucille Ball or look if you want
happy days or something like that they
get piece work I just changed my mind
I'm all-in I'm not doing it next weekend
I'm taking pictures with your mom you
would never do this Joe Rogan
like the other day a friend of mine home
and he goes I was at my dad's hospital
room the other day and it was the
funniest thing Joe Rogan young Joe Rogan
sitting around a campfire with people he
was I never saw an episode and also he
pulls on a bag of dicks and he made
everybody be dicks he goes me and my dad
[ __ ] Howard you know for some people
in ten years they're gonna come to you
and say can I take a picture for $10 I
love free effect we letting you sit
Nicole myself a picture I understand I
think it's a bad relationship it is but
some people that when they go to
comic-con yeah they take their whole
savings up there really good I'm sure
it's a shame what are you gonna do I
don't have any problem with it you have
any problem people doing to make a
living no no I'm just saying that's how
you get nailed that's how they know you
do you see yourself doing that I'm too
embarrassed that's what I'm saying
listen when I was a coke fiend I
couldn't sell CDs after a show so what
what does that tell you yeah I have just
to embarrass I'd rather shake your hand
and hug you and get the [ __ ] out then
you not come up to me because I'm
selling a $25 CD yeah that's a funny
thing about you Joey you know I've been
friends with a lot of guys that had
substance abuses like I told you about
my friend Johnny back in New York and
one thing that you both had in common is
that even though you have like these
issues there was never a point where I
felt like I couldn't trust you with
something you know like I you you never
would sell anybody out you would never
you know I'm saying like you wouldn't
you're not a type of person who would do
something to hurt somebody else so that
you could profit because you you were
sick and you needed drugs that was never
you you always had like a strong code of
ethics you know I would get out that
yeah we're worth nothing I was a jam
that had problems but when are we
started telling people he's a junkie but
he pays his bills yeah well you know
more like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about yeah you're just a guy struggling
in and I recognized in you a lot of what
I had seen in my friend Johnny was that
there's a lot of people that are
brilliant people that for some reason
the fabric of society just doesn't fit
them it just is
there's something about getting up in
the morning and going to a job and you
know whatever it is about the way they
were raised the experiences that they
had just who they are inherently from
birth
whatever the factors are there's certain
people that just can't do the regular
thing and they just need to find this
other thing for you is obviously stand
up and once you've found that other
thing it became successful that other
thing that's when your the whole thing
changed that's when you were I mean it
was really proof positive mean for sure
you learned a lot of things about life
you got older you got wiser you know but
I think a big part of you becoming more
comfortable and more relaxed and
becoming who you are today is that you
you've started becoming successful as a
comedian and when you started becoming
successful as a comedian like like well
10 years ago things started really
ramping up for you a noticeable relaxing
few noticeable change because you you
you realize like oh this is what I'm
supposed to be doing the problem is when
this isn't working and then you think
well maybe I should go back to selling
cars maybe I should get a job in a
factory
maybe I should maybe I should do
something a three or four nights a week
just bartend make a little extra money
lighten up the load on the family that
when when those cut types of things
start [ __ ] with you and that's when
you start doing coke that's when you
start going crazy that's when you stay
up late that's when you [ __ ] off that's
when you make big mistakes like you're
unhappy you're upset you're in the wrong
groove it wasn't the external struggles
as much as the internal struggles hmm
well maybe all of it together snow vine
this November's gonna be 10 years I
haven't done a lot of the coke iced
Ramon being calm it's amazing with you
the January after the November and you
know like you haven't done in 60 days
and I was still I wasn't sweating it out
yeah but I still wasn't trusting myself
right I thought I could snap at any
minute some chick with hot tits with a
gram of coke we had a remember bro for
me it wasn't about success or selling
tickets or for me it was just doing
something with my life right where I'd
come from all I wanted was just to do
something with my life
if I could pay rent feed the cats smoke
pot in two spots that's a lot better
than what I used to do yeah that's a lot
better than the life I had you
understand me even if I don't go on the
road and I'm not louis c.k didn't matter
to me
just I didn't have to carry a gun or
worry about people knocking on my door I
was like Richard Gere Nelson gentlemen I
don't know where else to go
go to the store and do that stupid spot
yeah at 12:45 and look what happened you
just keep showing up yeah man that was
another big part of it was getting you
on the internet that was the thing
so people we get a chance to show people
what I already knew you know like the
only way for you back then to get
exposure was you how to do something
conventional the only thing that existed
they had to put you in a movie or put
you in a TV show and you got in a few
movie movies and you got in a few TV
shows but they didn't get to see you as
Joey Diaz no but they got the see use it
like some [ __ ] character actor and
you know of that mob movie with Robert
De Niro but there's a big difference
between that and you like this you yeah
just it took that took the right thing
for you to be this you you know took
like the internet but now the Internet
is like for Joey is the best medium ever
yeah yeah there sure has exploded man
well for you too
that's gone yeah I like it you're just
as good of an example like you don't
have a lot of success outside of the
internet no that's true the Internet has
been your [ __ ] yeah I mean think about
it you didn't have like a long-running
television series or a series of movies
or anything you know yeah yeah but
you're selling out place is that a lot
of those guys can't even [ __ ] with ya
all the time because of your podcast
which is if you haven't seen it it's
your podcast with your wife's one of my
favorite podcasts it's so [ __ ]
consistently silly think it is very he's
so ridiculous yeah and people get silly
when they get on it they do and then you
know I start like seeing things like oh
this is like your mom's house bit I need
to send it to Tom yeah yeah they sent me
a couple good ones
I can't tell us straight about taking
this [ __ ] without 90 people hitting me
up the next day telling me that was the
most brilliant story in the world with
my son at the Thomson
play time I tell [ __ ] on the [ __ ] comic
it's awesome bark myself I'm two days
later sure enough I'm just wearing the
[ __ ] YouTube video replay Joey
telling [ __ ] stories for sure any told
us about when he [ __ ] in his backyard
and somebody thought a barrage yeah yeah
Joe Rogan's she looked at it and she was
like 58 she squinted at me up against
the wall I took a [ __ ] and I put my back
against the wall so when I [ __ ] when you
[ __ ] outside it's not gonna be a decent
[ __ ] yeah it's gonna be like explosive
and she's looking at the wall like what
the [ __ ] she actually walks up close to
it and looks around and runs it I'm
watching all this I can't breathe and
now I go to the computer cuz my wife's
very decent sitting there forever
just had a conversation with Susan I
want to get sushi give a go get sushi
eat a lot of it hey yeah the rice pushes
everything out yeah yes yeah you had
plans to go get a weed store you want a
post office but I made a detour I plan
to go home but I left the house key in
the house so I had to climb around the
window that's what happened yeah yeah so
when I pulled myself up I actually
landed with my stomach on the window and
now you really just made it push it out
more like fatter than [ __ ] and
hands are struggling the window feeder
on the other side
and the cats meowing scratching and I'm
like it's me your [ __ ] so I ran out ran
down the stairs oh [ __ ] outside
took a [ __ ] in Phaedra's backyard after
a five-hour drive to you can see the dog
[ __ ] it doesn't make you gag but human
[ __ ] bomb [ __ ] yeah you gotta clean up
some wine oh [ __ ] if you use one of
scrapers yeah it smells so much stronger
man when that Reese's Peanut Butter fuel
leaks out when you go to prison you have
to cut the [ __ ] up the [ __ ] like in a
tube while people watching TV like when
you go to County Jail you [ __ ] right
there
so black guys will be laying there
watching TV with their feet up and also
this small little [ __ ] they're like put
some water in that hole [ __ ]
like they're just yelling the other side
of the [ __ ] prison because that means
you took a [ __ ] in prison as soon as you
[ __ ] you gotta put water on it yeah but
there's some bathrooms that only give
you 20 ounces of water a day so whatever
time you flush it's gonna be a good
flush you follow me [ __ ] this sometimes
the piss has to stay there until the
next day until you take a good good [ __ ]
but when you take a [ __ ] in jail bro
they'll tell you cuz water put some hole
in that [ __ ] ol dog I could
smell that [ __ ] right now I'm trying to
watch Oprah but that's what smells one
stuff sucks it it's like when you go to
Vegas yeah they have that sucking action
yeah well if you think this [ __ ] this
big that's 34 inches once that suck it
breaks it looks like two new chucks once
that breaks it's over it's over they put
the bathroom right by the door the front
entrance yeah nobody come over right
right that's why I always go downstairs
take [ __ ] yeah I don't [ __ ] my bathroom
in the hotel no more cuz it kills the
whole room for two hours he worked at
the House of Blues in Vegas and Joey
left an on shore [ __ ] you know on shore
[ __ ] is it's like he he was so fat at
the time that he couldn't sit down and
like the regular toilet you were like
what do you want to do 4:15 he was a
giant
so when he would take a [ __ ] he would
had have to balance himself mostly on
the very edge of the front because his
ass was so big we didn't [ __ ] in the
water
well [ __ ] on the deck no you ain't never
seen a [ __ ] like that before so you
couldn't sit in the toilet I would sit
on the toilet but I don't like Milo the
bruise on the egg it wasn't that was fat
I don't like my dick inside the toilet
suck your dick and also in this
succulent toilet let my wife be in
public because I want to eat a monkey I
don't want that monkey so when I [ __ ] in
a public bathroom I hold my balls okay
and I [ __ ] towards the edge I don't give
a [ __ ] at somebody else's bathroom right
so you just hold your balls and sit
where you are because if I'm back there
I got crabs one time and they're sitting
on the toilet they'll jump from that
toilet inward like they jumping over a
moat people are saying they got crabs in
the toilet is an excuse
well sometimes you could greg crabs from
anywhere but i think you know we get it
from here they only cleaned the hairs i
don't think they like will stay on an
actual toilet i think you're probably
definitely right yeah i wouldn't feel
like that's one of those things like
crabs I took a [ __ ] a gas station that
had to be it that's what I always
figured it was know so I always hold my
nut [ __ ] when I [ __ ] it was long and
read bad
put ketchup on it remember red ban will
catch up unfortunately I think that was
a different time
okay this is not happening yeah there's
been many made those things just like
sticking out there's a smell you know
how when you take an epic [ __ ]
it's an above water [ __ ] it comes out
like like the [ __ ] Big Island of
Hawaii
yeah just Rises through the water yeah
like I've done that many times where cuz
I eat too much
yeah and I'll take these shits that are
just like so big they're preposterous
but there's a totally different smell to
those shits cuz you're smelling raw [ __ ]
outside of the water right I mean it's
it's it's gone through the water
yeah it's poking into this strong what
is it about that
that makes you happy what is it about
good doesn't come around that often
either yeah man it's like a comment like
it's like I don't this doesn't happen
all the time it's always diarrhea too
it's never like it's never like a super
like thick log it's weird when the
second wave is diarrhea like when you
take long [ __ ] you're proud of yourself
yeah and then you're like I think I got
a little more in there and it's like wow
it's just a [ __ ] you know that's from
what healthy eating healthy eating does
that yeah if you eat some MCT oil
coconut oil I do that to you lubes up
your pipes okay because where I moved to
now I have the office to back off isn't
it connected to a bathroom it's got a
door so I don't live with stink no more
I open the door in the morning I [ __ ] I
smoke the ball the backyard anymore no
no okay I door goes faces to the
backyard I had my own bathroom in the
bedroom then one of the guys nice oh I
don't put a woman oh [ __ ] no man there's
a school behind it kids playing I'm
[ __ ] smoking dope
I don't give a Frenchman's [ __ ] and it
don't smell him in homeboy you light a
candle that's beautiful beautiful that's
what you need is a bathroom with a door
that faces outside the worst is when you
go over a girl's house and you go to use
her bathroom and you smell matches oh
yeah oh no she was lighting this
[ __ ] up yeah
you think he's like burning off fumes
yeah
stinky buddy I hate thinking about her
meth ever get to a girl's place and then
you feel the gurgles and you're like
yeah I could I've had that before I was
dating a girl once and she had ferocious
diarrhea ferocious so she was in regular
yeah yeah and she so she went to the
bathroom and she just turned on to the
shower and she turns on both things on
the sink whoa
yeah drown and I'm like what the [ __ ] is
going on I was very young at the time
you didn't understand what I'm super
confused the [ __ ] is going on in there I
had I had once in in college where I was
at this girl's place and she was just
like okay it's game on like go for it
right like I have to take I could feel
that it was a diarrhea dirt like an
explosive diarrhea [ __ ] and I also
realized there was no way to do it that
then it would just be a black toilet and
that there's no way I could cover so you
know what I did I went back to my place
I was like oh I'll see you some other
time or what run the next day her
friends like you're like the [ __ ]
like they gave me credit but they they
thought was guy that I was a good cuz
they're like you're awesome yeah cuz
they're not getting [ __ ] they don't
want their friend to get [ __ ] right so
they use reverse psychology on you
you're an amazing guy I got an amazing
guy credit I hope you wait forever a
circle that you love not even when you
get married tell her we get married ever
so much have sex after you're married
never it's not about that right it's
about real love yeah like Twilight love
if I had had boughs that were intact it
would have been a different story that
night house boughs yeah yeah there's a
time when you know that it's in the
sensitivity of your inner [ __ ] region
I'm so amazed it is it knows yes special
you go to sleep out a fart right when
you like you like about to cut a fart
and and then also don't alarm start
going off oh no oh yeah oh no and you
got a clamp shot like Jesus what is this
we were having this debate yesterday
about why are they sometimes hot like
why is it hot and then why does why do
you know that hots gonna smell bad spicy
food bro is it but is that what it is
so imagine
I don't know I was telling you guys at
one time my freshman ya didn't take a
shift for a weekend I had high school I
was addicted to stake them American
cheese and all right a Frenchman well I
played freshman ball and we're playing
Pattinson Eastside it's just a jungle
over school like you got to be careful
you know on there and we went ahead and
played a Christmas tournament well what
kind of bar are we talking right that's
a basketball I hadn't taken his shift
like ten days I'm out got something I
took acid something [ __ ] my stomach if
I didn't tell nobody in those days I was
really scared of doctors and I would say
[ __ ] to nobody on the way home we got on
the bus and while we will wait there my
stomach started hurting I said Jesus
Christ eyelid off on my ship myself a
fart well let me just take a chance and
I blew this fart Joe Rogan that was so
bad right we want a bus and people
started running hero school buses people
started running to the windows right to
swing down the bus windows but his words
get better I fought it again and the
teachers were going oh my god he's
changing flavors the cheerleaders are
crying like this buffet was [ __ ]
god-awful I wrote a blog about one of
joeys farts once is that my plane yes
yeah I think I read that's called happy
pills and it was I was thinking about I
was I was looking at this ad
take this I was looking at this ad for
antidepressant
you know some girl dancing around a
field of wheat and [ __ ] you know those
those ads yeah I was just thinking about
like like what you know what depresses
people and how crazy pills aren't how
crazy oh it's still up there you can
still find it I think anyway at the end
of this this is a really fitting like me
we're both both of us are barbecued I
don't know what the [ __ ] what are we
edible some sort of edibles in the
beginning lollipops yeah way the
beginning we were crucified was asleep
yeah he was going in and out but he
wrote on the blog and I don't even have
to look at the fart was Troy he's lucky
I farted because it was a lot better
than the Antonio Banderas movie he was
watching something to do this on Tony
abundance movie I don't remember what it
was but I do remember the lady behind
you I will never forget hearing her over
the earphone yeah I hear oh my god over
the pounding sound in my ipod I hear a
woman in the row behind us cry out oh my
god I look over at Joey and he smiles
there's your [ __ ] happy pill right
there that's your right Antonia Banderas
Oh what was it oh yeah teaching
underprivileged youths how to salsa
that's what I was watching it was watch
the terrible move terrible we both were
and Joey farted the fart of all fart man
do you remember why the way we walk the
seat will you actually feel you like
when you're in a plane and it's coming
look down what's the button you push the
throat to see it was the seat belt into
your waist my god it was terrible but
another time I fought he's dead
I used take the number one bus from
Jersey City Oregon to the high school
and we were on the bus one morning kids
and there was a guy reading a paper I
could live to be a hundred and never
forget this reading The Daily News and
he had a connector of drool from his
lift the Daily News and there was a
puddle he was on heroin
they would go to Jersey City in those
days and get methadone so they would
take the bus up north with us so I'm
sitting there he's passed the [ __ ] out
and the drool is connected to the Daily
News and there's got to be just six
inches of power this guy's been passed
out for 20 minutes I point my ass at him
I'm not sitting behind them I'm sitting
across them yeah and I lift up my hips a
little bit that even if it wasn't
pointing at him he would ricochet off
the chair and go straight into his mouth
like he's sitting there and I let a fart
go out I can live to be 80 like this
first little buddy's like what yeah yeah
well [ __ ] giggling this is what this
is why I hate people this is why I hate
when I repo guy give me a second this is
this is the reason why I read posts some
people going are you sick and tired of
blue comedy will come down to the
Stanford feeder on Friday night and
listen to intelligent comedy comma for
the moment thought provoking comedy and
I think about how many times I'm 54
years old and that night I got a sleep
apnea machine arc and there's a little
needle in this sleep apnea machine
because the hall was punches air and do
your [ __ ] mouth so there's an escape
valve that's the size of a needle do you
know how many nights I will sit there
and be half asleep and I'll need to fart
and I'll wake up just to fart to see if
I could smell the [ __ ] fart come
through that hole yes
if it comes through the hole it's a
tremendous fun I just wake up my wife
like I got it you got it hell like it's
that good
I'm 54 years old that always makes me
laugh tops Tagore why do people say to
me just feel like I love
thought-provoking charlie dog that makes
you laugh it's comedy
yes it's comedy stop what's the [ __ ]
you know the uart
you almost hospitalized me one time from
laughing so hard like I don't know if
you remember this I'm serious I even
know if I could tell it it was it was
backstage his backstage in his show we
were somewhere and you were like how's
the way and you and I go you go where is
she and I said I said some city in
Tennessee maybe not though or Nashville
and you go Nashville 96 and you started
the story about working the club and
you're like I just rift and between
shows some crazy [ __ ] some chick who's
talking there was eight people for there
was 20 people for the first show
Knoxville it was a comedy zone show I
have booked it Knox knows a great little
[ __ ] town like a cute little
Tennessee town is it
it's like hip it's a fifth you know like
a college town so I get there on Friday
night Joe Rogan I'm headlining I got 38
minutes I just moved to LA and I signed
with creative management and they booked
those lumps so booking me out as a
headliner I was just dying slug that so
what they did was they put me in
one-nighters that paid by 275 and 9 they
weren't bad Tennessee you know and we go
to this Knoxville for two nights and I
go and then you know meet the UM [ __ ]
crazy
first night I go in there to from Friday
night there's 20 people for the first
show and there's a girl Joe Roland
that's a 12 with a guy that's a four
okay and it's her birthday
you know meanwhile through it she just
turned 21 it's a birthday okay what's
going on here you know cuz once you
start hearing noise you have to react
where there's a comment and you know
what's going on here only one I said
you're very beautiful and then she just
went and ran
and started talking about how her
husband pimps her out he would have
fights on and for 20 bucks you could
[ __ ] in the back world 20 fights were
on whatever I don't know that on Fridays
he would bring it to the construction
truck oh he was bring the truck with her
to the construction site and put a
mattress in the back and at lunch time
that he would let her friends and she's
telling me this it's like she's talk and
people like like just holding their
breath like what is going on here this
girl is beautiful and this [ __ ] is
just pimping so in between shows I go
upstairs to do a line a smoker clean
joint or whatever the [ __ ] I'm doing
when I come back I see her by yourself
when we start talking what's going on oh
my god I had such a great time I know
it's that stuff true
and she goes yeah go show me the monkey
and she took me in the woman's bathroom
pull down her pants the girl had a
monkey that was spotless she had nearly
stunk I ate it I offended her some and
then she sucked my dick that was it I
went back to my room anything that
mattered I'm like Jesus Christ I swore I
go back for the second show there's a
pee but by the time I go back for the
second show Joe Rogan she's sit in the
back she's doing one and she's looking
at me like this she's [ __ ] and ten
minutes into my spot said cuz I was
headlining she starts going I sucked the
comedian's dick tonight and the
husband's like what are you talking
about and she's like I sucked his dick
and he came in my mouth he's like what
the [ __ ] are you talking about the cops
had to hold him back he's like I want my
$40 that's all he wanted he didn't care
that his wife suck my dick at this
comedy bathroom when the cops came he
kept saying man somebody's gonna get
hurt if I don't have my $40 that's a $40
[ __ ] did you come and hung out yes if
I would become a little bit like 20 or
he cared about was the $40 dog so he
told me that backstage at your show and
I [ __ ] started hyperventilating $40
for his wife this is the world of comedy
ladies and gentlemen this is the world
of crazy [ __ ] comedy
Jesus you think that's crazy she's
crying some of the husband loved his
wife and said you know now he didn't
care he just wanted to $40 with a
[ __ ] I didn't give it to him he's got
rules I gotta give him that he's got
like a line in the sand this is number
four your buddies are [ __ ] crazy
animal when you sit at home at night and
you think about all the [ __ ] we've seen
we've learned a lot I'll think I ever
left is hard well that's by the second
time right then that road we've learned
a lot of things you learn a lot of
things about human beings you know a lot
of things about individual you learned
some grabbing them I did American home
it's a Armed Forces place in Idaho it's
part of the triple what this is I walked
in and I had to go meet do a sound check
everybody kept looking at me going hi
how are you
have you met sandy yet and I go no let
me go and they walk away you ever see
what's the movie with Eddie Murphy when
he blew my ring yeah when he goes to the
black chicks house it's 80 and the
butler keeps laughing remember the
butler would go yeah she wants to see in
the kitchen he would go because she knew
he was gonna she was gonna rape him so
every time somebody would refer to
Shirley they go do have you met Shirley
and you go no and they go oh and they'd
walk away well Shirley whoever the
captain of that base was the head of the
base she was his wife and if a bam came
to town or a comedian came to town she
blew him that's it that was the rule
like Hugh and he would sit out there
with his [ __ ] military on with all
his [ __ ] and clap and she'd be in the
back soup column Inc there's a whole
band I mean this is crazy so I didn't
know about this she came over started
talking to me and then she start to all
your Cuban I dated the Cuban one time
he's such a big thing you have a big
thing I mean it was that quick like she
just gets to it she's like 15 I was
maybe like 31 she's maybe 50
Wow and she just dropped behind the
curtain you took the hammer out
that's kind of soup element I'm sitting
there minding my own business and also
somebody comes yelling for Shirley
Shirley Shirley
now usually Shirley we get up and stop
sucking your dick not Shirley he moved
her knees like I had knee on belly right
that's what she did with her knees she
kept suckling just kept moving this way
she I tried to take it out of the mouth
she wouldn't let it
she's like no no no she foot closer she
wouldn't stop till I mean they're like
Shirley this is crazy [ __ ] I can't I'm
over stimulated
I feel like any psychiatric treatment
right now Minka juzu coming they cut it
short what is the word what does it mean
Minka me suck my dick make it in the
dialogue suka means suck right okay you
know it's so weird how the moistest
vanish
this is Italian Sicilian really so the
deeper you go down the boot the more is
it closer to Spain or is it farther from
Spain the closer Italy is from Spain
when people from that area speak Italian
I don't care how fast they're talking
they can't put the wool over me cuz I
could pick up every four words alright
so Sicilians say cyka what suck in
Spanish chupa-chupa you're in the
neighborhood right chuckle I mean when
they say su Chi Ming kia like like you
know what we're gonna do today and I'm
gonna go and get my mink you suck but su
column Inc is just a short shirt of this
show so calming sure and then you got
Ming Kia juice you want it cheers Cheers
when you when you hear those Latin
languages like you hear Spanish and you
hear Italian like those languages seem
they like feel like
have fun language you know everything
that's got a thing to it it's got a
rhythm
there's a way they talk it's fun yeah
listen to talk yeah especially not
really knowing anything about what
they're saying I could pick up like one
out of a hundred words maybe right yeah
and so I hear them talking them home
'but when was that but it's so for me
it's almost it's like here in the rhythm
of them talking yeah it's like a fun
sort of a smooth relaxed yeah but I get
you an expression you know they talk to
you it's very hard yeah yeah you can
always tell in a Latin person like
across a room yeah just by their hand
gestures and they start you know grazie
Mille grazie Mille like this just
hearing love please yeah how long will
it take your whole do you think it takes
you for you just to get the play if
you're in France for a week yeah like it
takes you three days just to get that
like I'm not gonna learn French in three
days but must take you three days to get
the jib like a monkey wrench like if
they come up to you and ask you what you
want from the menu like after you go to
nine restaurants yeah yeah you're right
you know three days yeah a little
something yeah yeah you get especially
if you have like a Latin root though you
know like you're comfortable with it
does it ever bother you when you hear
stories about Americans going on like
Paris and like the the Parisians
thinking the Americans were dicks the
Americans like acting like [ __ ] the
people from Paris like what is that like
how did that whole rumor get started the
loud American yeah the whole like you
miss versus Paris thing you remember
when they what they wouldn't call things
french fries they're calling home fries
fries like we're supply kits always like
the French you know like there's always
there's always like some weird like
right-wing punch line about the French
how much interaction feel like ever
Harry I think at this point for me it's
inherited oh yeah that's what I'm saying
I think it's everything about you
remember that episode of Sopranos woman
with David Lee yeah
yes chef can I get some red sauce he's
like come on red sauce marinara and the
guy looked at the other guy he goes if
you think these Germans are classless
you know I'm saying like look at this
guy he'll yeah like they all have every
country must have something towards yeah
I hear that we're haters across the
world but then well person like you or
you traveling you don't know bro people
were very nice yeah yeah they're nice if
you are nice and I think that's
universal people are nice if you're nice
yeah
pretty thoughtful people appreciate
pretty much everywhere people are nice
if you're nice you know and the way you
are changes the way they are you know
like if you run into someone and maybe
they're a little bit defensive but
you're openly friendly a lot of times
they'll relax that whereas if you run
into someone and they're sort of
defensive and you're aggressive with
them then it ramps up and the whole
thing becomes like some sort of a weird
ego disaster same person different
person interacting with them saying the
same words it's just it's it the whole
thing about people and the way we talk
to each other yeah
it's were it's a there's no one person
responsible for an argument yeah you
know most of the time it comes from both
sides and then how you interact with
people even if you feel like you did
nothing wrong
there's a lot of times like a big part
of how the conversation started shaping
itself
people don't want it's it everybody
wants everything to be black or white
right it's either like if you got an
argument when the dude it's his fault
or it's your fault but it could easily
be both can easily be like just a
mismanaged situation you know you might
been coming there because there might
have been some [ __ ] problem that they
were supposed to fix on your car and
they didn't and you know you in your car
headed to the Comedy Store you like this
[ __ ] and the light starts going
on again like god damn it and you get
there you already a little bit ramped up
and you run into someone and then you're
already coming at them at like a 6 and
if you get an interaction with them
about like hey man you can't get in
front of you I got
Oh someone you like [ __ ] you man right
that could happen totally does you don't
know where that's right you don't know
that's why I've always I twenty one I
learned a very important lesson life you
don't know what that guy's going through
today no one does right before you heard
remember some for you give that dirty
guy it's the hardest a finger and cut
him off yeah you don't know if his wife
just left him his kid just told him she
was a lesbian you know this is pie at
all sin he's got a girlfriend he does
have a [ __ ] gun in this car you don't
know what somebody's going through right
you have no idea what's on their mind
coming up to you you know one of the
most genius thing I ever heard was that
the great Carlo Gambino never answered
his own door he always had his wife
answer the door
well cuz no matter how mad a mobster
came over no matter how like he just got
off the phone with this [ __ ] guy and
he won't give me ten kilos Carla's gonna
resume this no matter how mad I came
into the house his wife would stop you
make you sit down and give you an
expresso don't give me Scott and talk to
you so by the time you got into Carlo
you were slowed down you think he was
very smart that way that's beautiful is
he always his wife was like everybody's
mom one of those ladies then you go how
are you so that's why it's not good for
everybody if men get together for long
periods of time I think that I think
that people should anybody who's
involved with customer service should
take some type of something to let to
calm people down like people work at an
airport right you know there's got to be
a system how to slow somebody down yes
that's a brilliant system having a wife
that's like a very nice person that sits
you down lowers you Detroit conjuring
talk to you and you realize like listen
this is what's important this kind of
friendship here like like half of the
issues that people get into it's a
perspective issue right it's like like
especially if you're like a mobster and
you think someone's [ __ ] you over and
you're like oh you know where's my
[ __ ] money and you said like come on
a perspective issue yeah it's it's most
what it is like how are you looking at
your relationship are you trying to [ __ ]
this person over you're trying to work
together in harmony
yeah we're just trying to work together
in harmony I better to work out we all
travel you ever have a bad travel day
and we get to a hotel and we'll [ __ ]
furious with that little lady at the
counter made us laugh and for sure all
about what just happened I'm sure and
she even do something that'll change
your whole outlook for the day like
she'll go oh by the way I knew you were
delayed
we told the kitchen to save your
spaghetti and meatballs on your way you
bad [ __ ] you Wow you know so
that's I liked when that happens I love
when I'm furious and I walk into a hotel
and somebody slows me down and talks to
me and so ya know it's really cool and
people have that that's a gift by the
way to actually slow somebody down and
be able to touch them and go hey man
it's gonna be funny come here let me
take it to detract them if you have a
business you have a customer service
representative someone who meets people
at the door that person has an amazing
personality that [ __ ] is worth a lot of
money oh yeah
sort of a lot of money can't coach it
you can't train yeah whether it's a guy
or a girl and I've met them on both
sides you know yeah you meet people that
work in a certain place where you look
forward to going back to that place to
saying hi to that guy that guy's just
super cool you like what's up what's up
man and like you've made like a
legitimate friendship with this person
and that's that's possible too you know
this idea that we all have to be
constantly at odds with each other and I
think even like security people like
when I see when I'm in a restaurant or
bar on a sporting event and I see a
security guy what's that word dissolve a
situation yeah Rhona points especially
when a person oh good one yeah that's
what a person's drunk listen I can [ __ ]
you when you're sober right once you got
four cocktails on you I'm gonna talk to
you once on my patients level isn't done
yeah you know it's [ __ ] done but
there's some people who stay calm they
go we know man
yeah let's just take a walk over here
and talk about it and you fall for it
next thing you know you're out bright no
matter if your girlfriend's with
the guy you know then he will come
rushing into a bar and this people were
tremendous at that that's a great gift
you know who could use that [ __ ] Big
John McCarthy Big John McCarthy is the
best at like separating [ __ ] when [ __ ]
goes sideways in the Octagon is in here
X police officer yeah yes yeah and he's
a giant yeah he's a I mean he's a big
dude is a black belt in jujitsu and when
when [ __ ] gets weird inside the Octagon
the cop and him comes out yeah like a
people if there's some chaos like some
crazy [ __ ] he puts a [ __ ] halt to
that no more yeah those guys are
important man it's important to have
people like that now that is a skill
though it is it's a giant skill and also
be a good guy which he also is right
like like Big John McCarthy is a hell of
a human by the way formally Congrats on
a thousand men that's really awesome
listen amazing party started guys
that's really incredible man it's
probably more right I think it's like a
thousand and forty three or something
probably yeah there's a bunch of other
named ones fight companions fight
breakdowns I would never ever dream when
you started doing these mean the other
day they would have the impact that they
have let's just keep that [ __ ] now and
void remember you like [ __ ] saying
like people want to hear this I remember
him calling me up to the room me yelling
at Joe and night why you [ __ ] the crazy
[ __ ] home on a Friday night
13-year old us take that [ __ ] off we
were in the green room and yeah no no
cops
no this was somewhere else wait this is
doing a pocket meet him in red bag
one of the first podcast we did was off
this thing called Justin dot TV yeah
Justin TV and we did the green rose and
we did him back when there were cellular
modems so you'd be streaming like there
wasn't like a lot of Wi-Fi back then so
we'd be streaming from like a cell phone
hookup yeah it was terrible
like real pixelated stuff but we were
like this could be [ __ ] weird have
people like
watches get ready in the green room
talking to the camera just bizarre so we
decided to do a few of those but Joey
was like get this [ __ ] thing away
from me but that was that was the
different Joey Diaz back then you know
you were still uncomfortable you know it
was funny with that that was the thing
that set you free it was also let people
know who you are at the beginning when
he was like hey do it weren't you also
like what the [ __ ] are you doing no no I
was like are you like a bird caller kind
of guy so like I thought it was like one
of those weird you know I mean things
that people do that I was like a bird
call like we talking about man and I
just didn't like it I didn't know but
then Dane Cook became a megastar with
MySpace and yeah everybody and their
mother one on my so that was before me
but they would not Dane Cook Dane was
doing yeah they just stopped by going on
MySpace and going I got free tickets
tonight yeah that that was gonna work
Dane Cook was communicating with that
true and people would see the
communication and go wow we can have
live interaction and blah blah blah but
Dane was doing that way before me he was
doing that on myspace in like 2002 or
something yeah right wasn't it but
pretty early on yeah but about in 2003
we'll check the lineup we'll check the
old calendars we did the fourth of July
weekend in Irvine and I'll never forget
that I said to you do you have radio and
you go I have no radio I'm a little
panicked and that Thursday when we got
down and the whole weekend was sold out
and that's when I said Joe Rogan's
aren't there some with that [ __ ]
computer I [ __ ] the [ __ ] cuz my
philosophy was that computer do you
think Richard Pryor would go home before
in the morning coked up and get on
[ __ ] Facebook that was my thing at
that time
sunglasses and think that [ __ ]
Richard Pryor's gonna go home and get on
MySpace so I was opposed it but once I
saw five sold-out shows in Irvine the
old Irvine when it was known that if you
didn't do radio nobody's gonna show up
there those great right that was it that
was it to me
that was what made me a believer that
there's something there
yeah it's amazing the the range of
people that come up to me about your
show you know like the like all types of
[ __ ] pilots fighter I've had like
amateur fighters professional fighters
the range of people that are interested
in your show you know I mean it's a
really wide range of people it's
fascinating
like it's really reached a lot of people
man I was it freaks me out man why I
wasn't Burbank okay all right you don't
me dog I had an I went to jiu-jitsu and
had a half-hour to kill so before they
had kind I just smoked a joint I was in
my car on Magnolia Boulevard up the
block from Porto's which is [ __ ]
backed and I opened up the sunroof and I
just started smoking a joint before they
had cut and I put a piece of gum in my
mouth and I actually walked in the
crosswalk to walk all across the street
and there was a lady holding a kid with
another one and a thing and she looked
at me and when she looked at mango [ __ ]
this lady smells me you know when yeah
when you don't have a child you don't
give a [ __ ] about reefer but when you
have a child and you see a mom with a
child you feel kind of [ __ ] sorry man
I didn't say no until she looked at me
she goes oh my god with the kid in my
thing and with the stroller she looked
at me she goes blue cheese with your
[ __ ] mother I loved it I'm from
Buffalo I looked at her and she just
kept walking but it was like the type of
woman that wouldn't say that to me with
the kid Edna push it she goes blue
cheese with wings they go [ __ ] your
mother I love you and she just kept
walking away
oh my amazing man what went to
Sacramento and families with kids it's
[ __ ] crazy but the realm of the
people why they come up to you and TSA
oh forget about TSA but the realm of
people and the reasons why that's what
I'm saying that's what's after which
always killed me like I've been around
for 20 years and what made you come to
my show as I told this [ __ ] about
I told the story about taking the [ __ ]
in somebody's backyard I loved it
we laughed like you like oh my god yeah
that's what you know when somebody comes
up to me it's always they came to a show
for something different I said on here
yeah you know that's really weird it's
amazing and like you said the contrast
it's not just the six-foot guy no it's
every the steroid a guy hits a mom with
a baby and a stroller I was saying I
love that I have people that so want me
to like it give you things it's so
annoying yeah they're like because they
always start with like trying to flatter
me and like try not they're like dude I
think you're [ __ ] hilarious
I know thanks man I love your [ __ ] I
listen to it all I was general on the
way to work every day I'm like oh thanks
a lot and they're like yeah man it's so
funny like I love this bit in that bit
and I'll be like it's very nice you man
thank you very much like it and I listen
to your podcast and I [ __ ] love it
it's so [ __ ] funny I'm like thank you
and then they're like hey would you give
this to Joe that's their their whole
thing like did you think because you
told me all those compliments I'm gonna
be your messenger and they'll be like no
I mean just like if you could give it to
them okay sure I get this request every
other week what kind of weird [ __ ]
that's always [ __ ] packages and
envelopes and I don't open them in good
yeah no they go right right I tell him
to send them directly to you and like
the cop he don't even do that he gave me
two cups I gave one to Alberto and I
gave the other one to you this is a
highly ineffective way to communicate
with people I sending them [ __ ] yeah you
know people think that I want to have
[ __ ] in my car I can't give this the
time like I'm gonna have this in my
[ __ ] bro I got the newest latest bong
it's totally different than this long
first of all you drop it out of an
airplane it will not break it's
military-grade brother this is the bomb
the bargain to end all bombs the
catastrophe Apocalypto you've had this
pay into the world bomb yeah sure bro
this bomb is made out of the same [ __ ]
the Wolverines claws
there's a closet in my office I slide
open yeah and I cannot tell you I must
have a 300 black t-shirt from different
vans and Sharons restaurants
I got every I mean look at me I got
every protein powder whew I got more
geez
yeah that's how many G's are given to me
yeah mailed to me I have to mail them
back my wife says if I see one more
[ __ ] I will throw that [ __ ] out it's
just amazing albums because people know
I like oh I come home with vinyl every
[ __ ] week really
some of it is [ __ ] atrocious yeah but
some of it is fantastic I listen to
everything you do do you have a hard
time chucking out old [ __ ] I feel bad
for people I understand that they've
worked for it and I understand that they
went on their way for it but if I
haven't seen Duncan in six months and I
got a bullish candle it goes in the
garbage like once Duncan moved to New
York I threw all Duncan shrooms
give me heavy drugs he's my brother
yeah you know what they come and get
some guy game about a month ago gave me
a book about stars and Jesus when I
looked he was the author that cast mmm
video that gets to him everyone that guy
gave me that book and I showed it to you
like how to be a real man one of his
rules was be 40 dumbest we went over it
on your pot yes right yeah and that guy
long he gave that to like a bunch of us
you we are Hong Kong he was like here's
this book I wrote let me look at it
it's him on the cover and it's all
glossy and he's in it he's like looking
off to the side and that was when I
first did your podcast I think you first
yeah yeah how many years ago was that
that was probably well we started at
seven years that's probably five years
ago yeah I do get a lot of neat [ __ ]
though
oh yeah I do get a lot of I'm talking
about plate you have the studio who made
that thing a kid in Cleveland yes that
thing is good I got I get great book
sent to me
I mean phenomenal money books I'm
reading one right now there's the
creepiest thing huh the three lives of
Jimmy Page from Led Zeppelin Oh
that [ __ ] travelled with a
fourteen-year-old girls bro
never got charged with statutory rape
really just travels the world for years
he's just a runaway on the on the tour
like [ __ ] crazy talks that true
you know talking about his house and
[ __ ] in where he lived he bought it
from Alex took it was aleister crowley's
all house a 24-karat warlock he was
Evelyn sure he lived in his house and
you know for some people it was like a
way to sell records and that for those
for those four were onto something
magical you know they were magical nine
albums but this book can I don't like I
gotta put it down for two days at a time
sometimes really yeah he's a [ __ ] nut
that's what's called the three live look
the ten wildest Led Zeppelin legends
record [ __ ] scroll the [ __ ] sit down Joe
Rogan he that hated a 14-year old Ricky
man the truth Maddux was amazing just 14
when she met Paige though Paige did what
he could to keep the relationship hidden
oh that's true that's crazy
oh that's weird he was crazy when they
shoved the little what they've shoveling
octa blah a baby shark up a sheiks [ __ ]
well that's so weird man like you could
you could do that back then right but
you could do weird [ __ ] back then yeah
it makes you stop and think like what
that is it's like the just the the
beginning of the Information Age right
newspapers regularly
television shows on the news all that
stuff was only like a few decades old
when the sixties and the seventies
rolled around when you really think
about the timeline there it's really
kind of fascinating do you ever think
about the jump from in technology from
like you know like you know how it's
sites that there's no Us Weekly there
right right so things kind of advance
and now everything's monitored and now
for instance you can you know you can
record a phone call right which is like
would be a difficult thing to do back
then or you can have a recorder running
on you do you ever think about how that
lat you know the privacy goes away and
how to some degree we can't even
conceive of it right now but how easy it
will be to record everything at some
point like how it'll you know we joked
that gets in your watch or it's in your
glasses but it will be like yeah you'll
walk out of every conversation and there
will be some some form to document it
yeah it'd be a total loss there's gonna
be there's gonna be some changes I don't
necessarily agree all right I'm not
convinced I should say not agree I'm not
convinced they're gonna be bad to do
that yeah I I just I wonder like what
what what's gained through this kind of
privacy now I'm not not talking about
like privacy like corporations or the
government being able to look into your
life I'm talking about we might get to a
position as human beings within our
lifetime where everybody looks into
everything about everybody everything
right finances your day to day life all
sexually yeah seeing you everywhere you
go no matter what you do like we could
get to a position where there's no
disconnection from any of us well we're
all connected to each other if this
keeps going the way it goes right so it
used to be everybody lived far apart and
you know you know ride a horse to get to
the friend and say hi and and talk to
him and hopefully he's still alive would
you keep back the next day you know but
there was no communication right then I
got the phone calls again as things have
ramped up and now it's a new phone and
now your phone's in your watch and now
your watch can tell you who's
on you and you can you can look at your
phone I see the person start track type
[ __ ] already happening right yeah and
it's getting deeper and deeper and
deeper people are streaming live
streaming live streaming Facebook no
matter what they do all day there's a
slew of people playing video games live
streaming people are tuning in watching
other people play video games I mean
we're getting like deeper and deeper
into this technological rabbit hole
where it becomes embedded in your life
in a way that was unimaginable before it
was introduced same thing as cell phones
before cell phones weren't introduced
who would have ever believed if you told
them that you were gonna get to a point
in human history where it is totally
common to see people staring at
electronic screens while they're all
sitting together at a dinner table that
there could be five people sitting
around and they're not even talking to
each other they're just staring at this
electronic screen and that screen is
compelling you know it I know it I get
drawn do it you get you're onto it yo
nose man might be some crazy news
let me check Google real quick you never
know you never know what weird [ __ ] has
been happening in the world and you get
sucked into this this thing is becoming
a part of your life in a weird way and
nobody anticipated if it keeps going in
the direction that it's going it's gonna
get weirder in a way we never
anticipated before where it's not gonna
be just as simple as put your phone down
and go outside it's gonna be your
phone's a part of you it's gonna happen
your phone's almost a part of you now if
you have to have it like I am connected
to this goddamn thing more than I touch
my dog right totally I love my dog but I
touched that thing more that I touch my
dog it's weird you want to pretend it's
not a part of me man I could just put it
right there so ah yes right there close
is right there
don't go anywhere I got you right here
that's basically a part of me it's
basically a part of me how long before I
let them open me up stick me there's a
spot my armpit I mean ooze there's a
great short about that there's a great
short film about is there yes what's it
called I don't I don't remember the name
of it but it ends up like under the
guy's skin that's gonna happen it's
funny I really I wish I had to stay away
from this [ __ ] thing I charge it a
different
and I you know the iPad I bought - right
no [ __ ] Facebook Twitter on not it
Neal Brennan tweet on an iPad I bought
an iPad do you have like one of those
little keyboard things you can't do with
the case like that bro it's changed my
life I used to have three hours of just
[ __ ] time a day that it's not enough to
work out so what do you write in notes
use notes program what do you yeah I
just write and [ __ ] notes and if I
don't like the joke that night I go back
and add the tag you know what's real
good if you ever try Evernote no I
Evernote is real good allows you to use
pictures all kinds of different things
that black ever out everything else no
no that's a different thing that's a
right room but Evernote you you if you
write things like the things you want to
remember maybe before sets you can write
them down in Evernote and then sync them
from your iPad to your phone and back
and forth it's really good
that's it's one that I use I just got
this iPad pro three weeks ago and it's
changed my life
yeah that's it changed my life I could
give a [ __ ] about Twitter Facebook
nothing when I go to that coffee shop -
right it's just that program I have or
everything else in there but I haven't
even programmed I have the apps in there
I got my fitness plan in there I got BJJ
training Journal in there and that's it
you know that's it think about the
Internet man I think about the internet
like I think about foods that are sweet
like you can have them as long as you
don't have too much so much don't still
love you crazy that's that's how I feel
about even going online I think we're
we're we're we're getting to this weird
point where we're just relinquishing our
consciousness to this machine
relinquishing our consciousness our
connection that we all enjoy it's not
our consciousness it's the consciousness
were all sharing about a certain topic
yeah we all have to interject on what we
think about Charlotte though for about
Trump but stuff like that these days you
get on Facebook and Twitter and you're
[ __ ] sad you get sad like you get sad
for people yeah okay I make it a habit
Friday's out here son there's no reason
to be on the internet you have to stay
away from it there's no reason the shows
are sold out your family's at home
what do you want to tell me this is my
this is my cheeseburger yeah I give a
[ __ ] so on the weekends I don't touch it
I forced myself don't touch it for what
you have to have a life man
yeah we are we are forgetting that
there's a life you ever go to a park and
look at these [ __ ] parents look at
their phones you go to park where your
kid don't you yeah I don't take my phone
out of the car at the park
there's no call you you manager I will
tell you they change your spot at the
store from 1015 to 10:30
if you wait you're kidding your wife you
don't need your phone you really don't
Joey you gotta get in the floating man
how come you don't float because I smoke
pot and I think of this [ __ ] on my own
yeah but it's different that's why it's
not it's all you think he'll be fine
Becky works at the place in Pasadena
uh-huh
and we've been talking about it a lot
about it I'm really scared about these
little dabs of anxiety that I get from
Joey you'll be fine
Allyson it's good for your health no I
know it's good for my health but when I
go get give blood like yeah I'd add a
little blood no problem wait does weed
make you more anxious or less anxious
and smoothes it out okay so when it
comes to certain things I have to see a
window like it's really weird yeah right
now there's not a window in it I see
that [ __ ] door like when I walk up
the steps at the original room and I get
anxiety what a comics on stage it could
be any but could be an open mic when I'm
next
and I start getting this this shortness
of breath I have to turn around and look
down the stairs at the Comedy Store just
by me knowing that I could get out if
[ __ ] goes down I'm okay mmm so I don't
think a [ __ ] tubs got windows a
floating tank they seal that thing over
you know they don't see how it's just
felt or that's what I'm a little scared
of it's it's really I'm not
claustrophobic either I was in the cell
none of that [ __ ] bothers me I just got
to see a window yeah well listen it's
it's real easy like when you're lying
it's right there
you just peek lift your hand up it's
right there the doors right there no we
have stand-up you open the door it's all
in your head you know look what happened
yesterday in Spain
alone what a [ __ ] shame you can't
connect terrorist attacks quickly let me
ask you a plan let me ask you a question
my brother okay you're an intelligent
individual you're an intelligent
individual Tom Segura Jamie you're not a
[ __ ] Phi Beta Kappa but you know
smart it's getting the right now I'm
just using you Jamie how many people
were looking down when they got hit by
that car yesterday let's be honest
well that's 65 people got hit but you
know why people oh well that's you know
people are wandering through that's
start paying attention as Americans you
cannot live in that [ __ ] thing no
more hmm we cannot it's not smart it's
not smart to be walking around staring
[ __ ] but sometimes you have to look
at it you know there's there's times
where like someone of course sends you
an address
you're meeting people there there's
yourself you're like what am i doing we
have children do we want our children to
grow up on a [ __ ] computer do we want
them to have experiences both they're
going to grow up on computers you're not
gonna no I I want them to grow up in
computers but I don't want that whole
lifestyle to the other computer I want
them I go outside I want them thrive
dirty yeah I wanted to have life
experiences even if you know the only
way you learn about life is sometimes by
having a negative something negative
happening so true then these children
that are on a computer to the eighteen
and they send them away and they [ __ ]
fracture yeah they fracture well it's a
different time now for children guys and
we're parents it's a different time it's
way different it's different in a way
that I don't think anybody has ever seen
before so they don't know what the [ __ ]
to do they don't know what the [ __ ] to
do Tom's gotta pee ha ha look how slim
he is you look beautiful beautiful sex I
tried rainy but as normal as I can I try
to keep as normal as I can and then we
want to forget who the [ __ ] I am Joe
Road
well you won't and I don't want to
forget it for my children wait order you
know I don't want them yeah damn why I
was driving home okay and I saw a little
girl selling lemonade with her mom on
the
it was 2,000 degrees in Studio City I
plucked to my house I go inside and get
my daughter and I get to my my wife well
let's go buy some [ __ ] lemonade from
this kid all right my daughter's going a
kindergarten next year at a school
that's like rated one of the highest
schools but it's a public school purge
kids go there bunch of kids go there's
no reason to put your kid in these notre
dame's and all these $25,000 they want
thirty four thousand dollars a year for
kindergarten why come on djaro how is
your child gonna benefit come on we're
all intelligent here that's thirty four
thousand dollars monarch Notre Dame all
the schools in the valley they want 30
G's two G registration forms to sign
you're kidding really generally people
want to keep their kids safe no it's not
safe it's so you could tell your friends
that your kids them [ __ ] that school
that's what nice little bit his eyes yes
at night oh no my kids attend and you're
like oh my god and you're kiddin attempt
to be a [ __ ] dummy because he's in
school with other rich people's [ __ ]
kids yeah and they're all [ __ ]
dummies - you know they're getting
raised by [ __ ] nannies I don't want
that mmm I don't I go to the park how
many [ __ ] white kids do you see with
Mexican women they ain't got a [ __ ]
shame behind these Mexican women I
redacted white kids that's [ __ ] up
that's why they didn't want Trump to
build a wall cuz you have to raise their
own [ __ ] kids that's why these white
people didn't want Mexicans to go in
California who's gonna raise their
[ __ ] kids
oh jeez swimming cool I go to swimming
class Tuesdays and Thursdays with my
daughter
jump on the [ __ ] there's no more white
parents with their kids ten nannies are
in the [ __ ] why I'm here with the
kids when your kid grows up and he's
what's his name my Govan Apple oh my oh
yes don't come crying to me pacifier
there were six I was raised to be a
little [ __ ] but I snapped out of
it somewhere do you know that my homey
this my father died I wanted I was one
of those little boys you see with that
mom holding on to that leg no go I was
one of those little [ __ ] [ __ ] kids
yes
okay I sucked a pacifier to the age of
six okay I had potential to be one thing
one [ __ ] thing you understand me
but my mother would not allow that [ __ ]
to happen they don't Latin Mother's
don't play that [ __ ] yeah I'm saying oh
yeah Latin mothers do not allow that
[ __ ] I couldn't wear scarves you know I
was a lot the wanna wear scarf like a
Snoopy scarf or like a plain scarf or
what's it like one of those Randy
Couture scarves which although I
wouldn't wear I think on him is quite
fetching
no no scarves - no all you ever see the
Randy Couture scarf no yeah Randy
Couture will wear what I would call a
tactical scarf Oh like that
yes that's the kind of scarf that like a
Navy SEAL would wear that
Brandi wears a bunch of those things but
Randy's such a bad [ __ ] it's
almost like he's begging you to try to
choke him with yeah man come come try to
grab that thing that should be the name
of that album right there that should be
his album cover I'm a ready coachable
yeah about anything you know what and
his kid his kid came to my show in Vegas
and also has like a gym there coolest
coolest kid men like him and his wife I
think both teach there - Wow nice - his
son his son is yeah I saw uh I think he
was fighting in the world series of
fighting which is now now I was a new
name but yeah he fought for a bunch of
different people right dignified for
Strikeforce and I think he might have
fought for Bellator Ryan Couture
talented fighter hey while we're at it
don't forget to remind you has [ __ ]
Gino giving you the CBD roll-on yet yes
what do you think it's amazing how does
it even work that voodoo go the other
night I came home I supported like a
cream you rub it on like spots really
get out of the shower
done it gets in weird spots yeah done
its must have some sort of
anti-inflammatory properties or
something like that do you like that
Thai liniment everybody
never rub that stuff on you know I like
ties like Thai boxers and [ __ ] they're
like you gotta realize we're always
dealing with like bone slamming into
their legs yeah they're all sore and
[ __ ] and they rub this like Thai
liniment it's weird it's like he'll
smelly stuff I don't think it heals the
man but it makes sure feels good what's
the shoes that's a similar one Tiger
Balm [ __ ] I have another thing it's
called something juice and when I was a
kid I used to have the high end pound
bag and I would rub down on my hands and
do the iron palm tech making [ __ ] with
that it sparked something that has a
weird smell to it what does this stuff
do like when when that stuff like heats
your skin up and you're like oh god like
icy hot like that kind of [ __ ]
what is that really doing I have no idea
I think he's just tricking you into
think so oh yeah I don't think it really
is someone who's a friend of mine is a
doctor described it as a topical
analgesic meaning that it does something
to surface just can't but maybe is it
psychological that makes you feel like
it's healing up like when you have a
muscle soreness or something like that
yeah injury well there's a psychology
psychological aspect to that heat stuff
I feel like you think you're getting
work done you know there's probably a
psychological aspect to healing in
general yeah I mean I don't think it's a
hundred percent but I think you could
sway it in a better direction yeah you
know I mean like that's got to be what
the placebo effect is right they tell
you they're gonna give you a pill and
it's gonna make you feel better you're
like ah this is it this is the thing
they gave me the gave me the pill and
you actually do feel better and even
show signs of recovery like immediately
corresponding to you taking that pill
like your brain is convinced yourself
what about that dude you've had on the
podcast whose brain is like a [ __ ]
healing serum who can walk wim HOF yeah
wim HOF oh yeah dude he's I mean he's
people he teaches people how to do it
he's as legit as they get he holds the
world record for swimming under ice ice
yes and by the way he [ __ ] up and
couldn't figure out which way to get out
because his retinas had frozen over
because the water was so cold how does
he do this he's an
and mo he's a [ __ ] savage that guy in
the most beautiful sense of the word he
just has incredible breath control
that's a big part of like his whole
entire philosophy so the guys following
this rope all right once he's committed
to it by the way like he's just got
these little spots along the way where
he can get some air but he lost track he
couldn't see good anymore because it was
so goddamn cold he couldn't figure out
where the exit is
so he went more than the full distance
that was his goal in the first place
which was insane all of its insane
[ __ ] a man I mean that got something
special he teaches people which is the
crazier part even to me that he's he's
gotten people trained them to swim in
like freezing water
oh yeah walk through ice and also fight
off a cold yes yes [ __ ] man I use his
breathing technique before I go on stage
and what I do I have better shows this
is what I think I think you look kind of
hyper oxygenate and stimulate your mind
how sophisticated this is breathing -
well it's a lot of what he's it does
that I find beneficial is like and I've
heard this concept in yoga before - is
breathing in like I took a giant breath
and letting out excuse me
letting out about 20% and then breathing
in again as hard as you can and letting
out about 20% breathing in as hard as
you can and then continue that for like
long periods of time dude I do that in
the the cryo tank where I stand in the
cold air yeah three minutes goes by like
that there's a giant difference between
when I do that and when I don't do that
so you focus on your breathing
it's a little bit of that there's
definitely there's there's something
about people that are encountering any
sort of stimulation where it's real hard
to manage the stimulation without
letting everything get [ __ ] crazy and
haywire yeah and being able to manage it
has a gigantic effect on what the actual
results or the actual experience of
being this cold is yeah yeah because it
gets the same goddamn thing but if you
can control your breath and control your
consciousness
and you're doing something that seems to
be heating up your body - in a little
bit of a way almost like an internal
exercise because it's difficult to do
because you're taking these big giant
breaths of cold air and then you're
letting out a little and then you're
taking a big giant breath it's almost
like you're flexing your lungs yeah and
when you do that man I mean it might
make it 20 30 percent easier to deal
with three minutes supposedly I'm not
kidding one of the elastics I don't know
what year is if you'd like to check Jay
the Russians beat the [ __ ] out of the
Americans suppose the Americans came out
walking out you know the flag and the
Russians all came out going cool cool
hello and they couldn't figure out what
the [ __ ] is wrong with these
[ __ ] that's what they were
doing they warm up their lungs they look
back to think about what they're about
to do the technique they're about to use
and to let the blood go to the back of
something [ __ ] me and I read about
that was pretty interesting whether it's
true and I don't know but supposedly
that cardio was so ahead of the United
States because they were doing a pre
breathing exercise yeah some to do know
is that the guy that also has the record
for the deepest drop I think it's a
different guy that's a different guy
that's a different guy he's the one that
I wrote that I read about he's the one
that wrote about that how you have to
prepare for all that stuff hmm that was
learned when the Russians came on the
Olympics and it's interesting to focus
on your breath like I don't do it much I
do it I actually been doing Pilates and
it's way [ __ ] a harder than I thought
it was gonna be but be like you're
thinking about your breath for like an
hour basically you're always you're
always working on your breath there's
it's not it's not a secret that like the
greatest jiu-jitsu guy of all time had
this crazy breath control really pics
and Gracie yeah there's a bunch of
videos of him you've received a
documentary joke you ever heard of it
no it's an amazing documentary about
this guy Hickson Gracie who's almost
universally regard as the greatest
jiu-jitsu player of all time yeah and
fought a bunch of fights and MMA and
strangled everybody fought but he
there's this video where he's doing this
yo
warm-up sort of thing that he would do
every day and he does this thing with
his stomach that you watch him do this
and he starts warming his stomach up
he's doing this like fire-breathing [ __ ]
but then he starts sucking his stomach
into like the upper corners of his rib
cage like rhythmically and it's like
almost impossible thing like when you're
watching him doing it like he's warming
everything up and then once he gets it
warmed up he starts wiggling the
internals but look at this man who the
[ __ ] has that kind of control of your
abdominal muscle this guy would do this
like every time he trained he did it all
the time did it constantly he did this
he did yoga constantly gymnastics he did
a type of yoga called gymnastic
natural which is a Brazilian sort of a
combination of yoga and a lot of like
movements like rolling and animal-like
movements natural movements amazing
stuff see if you can find the guy who
created that gymnastic natural so you
give the guy credit cuz there's a really
amazing style to work out yes yeah or
into gymnastic as a couple brazilian guy
teaching that's the boys is actually so
much more badass than its given credit
for jiu-jitsu no no I'm talking about
like gymnast Oh
jaren s4 yeah or even like yoga masters
their physical ability is so beyond I
think most people's perception of it
when they first you know think about it
like yeah [ __ ] psychos man professor
Alvaro Romano is the guy who created
gymnastic unnatural hmm and that was
Hickson's thing and there's videos of
him doing it doing it on the beach
there's a video of Hickson doing it and
you will you watch the movement and you
go oh this is almost like he's having
like it's almost like shadow fighting
with jiu-jitsu because you're being able
to put your body in these weird
positions over and over and over again
and balance yourself yeah well it's all
about just controlling your body and
weird way that you could possibly
encounter a position we'd have to be
strong yeah wild [ __ ] because he was way
ahead of the curve man there was
everybody back then was doing Mexican
supplements and deadlifts and bench
pressing and [ __ ] you know running
over each other in training camp beating
the [ __ ] out of each other and Hicks it
was just strangling people ya know it's
really a fascinating thing when you stop
and think about it that this one guy was
the best and so far ahead of the curve
and so few people even people that
really got into jujitsu saw well first
of all you had amazing talent as dad was
a Leo Gracie those are two giant factors
but also the way he trained and the way
he controlled his breath and his own son
Chrome Gracie's one world champion when
the best grapplers in the world
can do all that stuff - he has massive
breath control and he'll tell you it's
all about your breath like being able to
control your breath is a massive part of
your anxiety levels
it's a massive part of how you can deal
with stress how you can calm yourself
down you have control and power over
your lungs what is this - doing oh this
is a no he's out there in the jungle
this night guys actually doing it in the
jungle like Jacare does a lot of that
stuff we all breathe naturally won't
like if you look at your children
they're breathing the way that it was
supposed to breathe yeah yeah somewhere
where with 10 or 12 will become a
teenager yeah we go off and like my
breathing was completely I went to
seminars I went to did you really well I
went to jiu-jitsu I created so much fear
in my mind from being on my back that I
would immediately run outside and take
my gear off and pee my pants and most
people would quit like I just pee a
little bit of my shorts remember most
people would have quit you know I don't
like that feeling yeah so I kept calling
back and I wouldn't improve
I wouldn't improve because of my car
yeah I've been smoking joints for 30
years
yeah I'm a fat farm yeah it was that I
had a build like I had to get bas Rutten
his mouthpiece to build my diaphragm
just yeah to suck I had no therapy all
this because of jiu-jitsu
really
legette bas Rutten thing is legit when I
hit the bag I use the bathroom tank yeah
I think what they're saying is the best
way to use it is use it as an exercises
exercise I use it use it like an
exercise set up do a few things with it
and just blow some air out with it like
really good it's really helped me but
that's how much I've learned about like
I know I don't have as much anxiety I
breathe it out it really [ __ ] so I've
did a lot of reading about it but that
guy's article but the guy that dipped
the longest his was the most interesting
I didn't know but this time the [ __ ]
ice is [ __ ] but it's true man once you
now I'm rolling and now I pull guard all
the time just to be on my back I want to
be fearful yeah so I just could I just
look back whenever I have a problem I do
a thing called hula boo that the Indians
did hula where you look hookah hookah
Lou or something like that oh who could
ow who kalau where you look up a new
center again yeah
and that's helped me become a better
common sometimes you're up there talking
[ __ ] you just center yourself and all
these little things I learned because I
joined you Jitsu like my breathing up I
focus on it when I Roma I don't care
about hands no I don't care if you choke
me I really don't give a [ __ ] I'm
horrible anyway I'm just I'm just
learning to breathe all over yeah you
know I'm just learning to breathe you
know you know I was grabbing you and
then trying to go for a cross collar and
then [ __ ] like doing something
completely different for a scissor sweep
and somebody's eye Joe you gotta exhale
brother just do you do you do you do
yoga for Jiu Jitsu don't they have a
class like that down it yeah yeah yeah
we do I go oh what's the name of the
actual that thing is called TAC fit but
I go to yoga with my wife once a week we
just go League she goes four times I
just go with the Tuesday one just to
loosen up from 10:00 to 11:00
I'm not that good at it my past fit is
our friends track fitters are Scott
stone and Ozzy yeah damn colossi who did
the podcast may have [ __ ] have a
tremendous
workshop this wrecking [ __ ] the
five-o what [ __ ] sadly and suddenly
wasn't they teaching you kettlebells
meets club bells with glassy and how it
affects jiu-jitsu and MMA and something
like that so last week I got to meet
Scott sunny and boy he's [ __ ] great
he's got a lot of great stuff of great
luck bells
yes Gracie some of his videos like this
I'm up to the 20 pounds from Marbury
yeah I started first got the club bells
from Aubrey my wrist was hurting with
five pounds I couldn't even do the
simple five pound one now I'm taking 20
he's holding them going all the way back
well bringing them back and it's all
focused on my back and breathing that's
it I just do [ __ ] to breathe now I don't
give a [ __ ] if I get beat up because
that's what was really bothering me yeah
breathing man even getting better at it
yeah but now I'm getting better at it
plus the sleep apnea had put a lot of
fear so being on my back and being out
of breath to sleep at and here we're
kicking again frightened you know so
never do those shield casts remember the
Iron Sheik remember the Iron Sheik used
to hold up those gigantic Iranian clubs
yeah that they would use for wrestling
training it's like it was a really
strong move for wrestling training see
if you could find one with the Iron
Sheik cuz he was like the Iron Sheik
people who don't know he was a pro
wrestler in the WWE was WWF back then
and you know he was before he was that
he was a super successful Iranian
amateur wrestler like he was a legit
wrestler like legit wrestling skills and
ridiculously strong and he's holding
these things I don't know how much these
things weigh but they it doesn't look
like he's faking this because of the
slow motion of how he's moving it they
look like heavy objects I don't know how
much they weigh but this is a really
hard workout to do you know I I can
barely do that [ __ ] with like 15 pounds
and I'm not bullshitting with one hand
it's hard
it's a weird control thing and you
realize like how you're strong in
certain areas those are definitely
heaviest [ __ ] the heaviest [ __ ] yeah
here's
wrong in certain areas like that guys
super jacked who is that it's got
beautiful anywhere but it's it's a very
difficult thing because you could be
really strong when it comes to like a
straight shoulder press
you know like hoist up like 70 pounds
but there's no [ __ ] way in the world
you're gonna be moving around 70 pounds
you're just you just can't do it yeah
your arms gonna fall off like if you
have especially if you have it in the
form of a club like you can't even get
close like I can do a lot of [ __ ] with
heavy kettlebells but when it comes to
like one of those clubs I take two hands
to move around a thirty pound one right
which is correct like if someone says
like 30 pounds like do you benchpress 30
dogs bro that's all we got here get up
off doing something with one of these
clubs that's 30 pounds is [ __ ] insane
I'm saying you have to be so goddamn
strong and that sounds weird because it
seems like well 30 pounds of 30 pounds
when you start swinging that [ __ ] over
your head and it's long and so like the
leverage is going against you look at
him I've retweeted him the other day
about Nazis I love him I was on stage
with him in Toronto one of my favorite
moments as a human calm people jabronis
yeah I called everybody he's a good man
and he was a stud wrestler but there's
that's the dark secret of not just
professional wrestling but of just real
high high level grappling it's like the
damage that gets done to a lot of those
guys bodies is almost unfixable and he's
all [ __ ] up now he's got you know Ric
Flair's like not in a coma but in like
isoloop like last four or five days yeah
I heard about that and how old's Ric
Flair yeah you know um they pay a price
they pay a price to to entertain in that
way very very physically violent you
just because it's not quote-unquote a
real fight words like there's an
unplanned outcome and just throwing
haymakers at each other like a real MMA
fight just cuz it's not that doesn't
mean that they're not taking in a lot of
damage
yeah hit with those [ __ ] forearm
shivers and dropped a [ __ ] chair on
them like all that [ __ ] is [ __ ] them
up a lot of them have brain damage to a
lot of I'm sure there's no sure there's
no Studies on it but I'm sure yeah I
mean I'm sure some of them avoided it
you know some of them fought smart and
what is he saying well is that boy
saying your song I thought it was
Halloween well he said drop a
[ __ ] bees oh my god so long
what song is that oh it's a Halloween
song right the place what's that face so
mind playing chick something yeah that's
it with whatever we triple-teamed on
them dropping them [ __ ] b's the
more I do the more I swung the more
blood flew then he disappeared and that
my boys disappeared too wow that's a
classic man oh my god Bushwick bill
ladies and gentlemen yeah remember the
one with a [ __ ] the cover of a ghetto
boy CD is Bushwick bill with his eyes
shot out in a [ __ ] nut not even this
one it's another one in the gurney
right to the hospital and it's like we
can't be stopped is the end with the
album he got shot hilarious man I think
he shot himself in the eye I don't even
know what the [ __ ] happened someone shot
him in the eye and he's like we can't be
stopped and using the gurney like look
at this oh yeah right
damn yeah so he's on the phone he's got
one of them brick yeah he's got one of
them brick cellphones from the olden
days from back at the gordon gekko today
these guys on playing games yeah and so
he got shot in the eye and while that's
happened he's on the phone doing deals
doing deal still doing deals who was the
common money today hat I guess they were
pushing they said whoa
why don't we take a pictures we can put
this up exactly yeah yo yo yo yo we
gotta take a picture let me take this
bandage off right quick oh my god man
yeah the who's the [ __ ] that's and
that's horrible nomenclature Sir John
Wesley saw him [ __ ] changing the flat
one to the Houston really and he pulled
over to help Bush week bill how cool was
that
Bushwick bill I met what is he a show
once he came to a show did you yeah it's
got one of my favorite quotes all time
he got without a hoe be a hoe it's
totally he's totally right that's
hanging really did shoot his eye out
really did
oh yeah that wasn't a publicity stunt
look at that
yeah that's crazy man met that face
walking up to you
they were like at a store I'm a
celebrity oh my god [ __ ] I shot out
they were [ __ ] huge at one time
ghetto boys for sure to life that you we
can't be stopped we can't be stopped as
a big [ __ ] album they were huge
no yeah I still listen to them when I
was on the treadmill
[ __ ] Stairmaster things whatever the
[ __ ] is rap a lot right doesn't that
Houston label wasn't that rap a lot yeah
they put us on the map
yeah rap a lot that's exactly what it
was that's right with the teeth Oh Paul
wall yeah he still makes teeth that's a
good idea for real that's a great
Christmas there's some death squad
grills and let's [ __ ] do it will you
do it please please do it how many teeth
how many just get a romance before oh no
like a top sir Bob would we go to Paul
and that for sure oh wow what's up Joe
Rogan's 1,000 baby got your lips no it's
fine man what if it gets hooked up on
your wife's [ __ ] that's that's cool too
if it's diamonds should be cool with it
yanking out of there touches it for the
denture grills how much with denture
girls let's see that what's the cost on
that there you go those are ones you
slide right off and on looking diamond
grill yeah right what about people that
want to be diamond that's 2400 whoa
$2,400 for jewelry and your teeth just
to let everybody know you're not playing
buying right if you meet a dude he's a
number of gold teeth like the number of
gold teeth he has direct proportion as
to whether or not he's a pirate dude
shoot your next special wearing these
[ __ ] let me know what timing is
meant I'm serious JRE and then put the
name of the fresh on the bottom I need a
hype man I've been thinking the colony
on this I would love to you to figure
out like what's my best strategy I'm
trying to hype out is that a word you
know I would do as soon as you hit like
a big punch line I would go and that was
[ __ ] funny to get them wrapped up
even more Elkin John make sure you just
showing up and going yeah yeah fifty
grand the [ __ ] I'm sure man well
what's the matter John stays pay was
like Paris Hilton was like one of the
biggest things she had was like those
nightclub appearances she'd go in there
just pay or go rip the money yeah just
show up some guy gave her a club that
was called like Club Paris Oh everyone
was supposed to come show up and like
cuz she's supposed to be there every
weekend right she's not going to Orlando
every weekend obviously it was that the
idea that he had how coked up are you I
know I'm going in business with Paris
Hilton I gotta write yeah we'll give her
a club that cool you see it you see the
connection if you're if you're hearing
this guy who made that deal I'm sorry I
was joking around I don't really think
about one day were [ __ ] that hot like
we first going to the comic store sunset
when you hit Laurel Canyon
it was bumper-to-bumper traffic right
okay it was bumper the beer traffic I'm
gonna be getting a ticket one time cuz I
have my spot was up I just learned in
the middle way there was a cop right
there [ __ ] way
by the standard hmm you know that was
when the help and what's the other chick
that was getting in trouble Lindsay
Lohan's yeah they were out every [ __ ]
night sure cause I'm prom and then
Lindsay Lohan went to the griddled
before court one day she went to that
place that we went to the breakfast
place yeah good place and now is it
after that the griddle was back for
[ __ ] months after that because people
thought Lindsay was only going there for
breakfast every morning they had those
crazy pancakes right it's like good
thanks I mean but I'm saying that it's
like 18 pancakes and one day like
there's your pancakes nuts no you don't
kill you
thank you you do they certainly offer
you like 15 years ago that was fresh
stuff yeah friend yeah 15 years ago they
had coffee from like Hawaii there yeah
they were doing a good job there I just
don't like waiting on life thanks bro
I'm anti waiting on one I'm not amazed
I'm waiting in line we face a period for
restaurant I mean when something kind of
reasonable fine obviously it's like your
table you know the table use to hang it
but when they're like this place is
awesome just hour and a half like have
you ever done the rankings barbecue in
Austin get more [ __ ] help and come
out and get more [ __ ] waitresses the
what's the hamburger place they do it
yeah I think it'd be cool some people
sit there for eight bucks an hour for
you Ari likes that [ __ ] does sit in
there listen nothing I don't want to
wait for nothing
when I go to breakfast in Hollywood yeah
I stopped by the griddle first yeah why
get is it still nuts there it's still
little wine yeah well if they give me
any drama there's a bagel place across
the street that's tremendous yeah you
get a nice clean turkey Bobby they make
fresh front and Turkey and put on your
bagel Bobby ain't [ __ ] around check
the best wizard job at all Hollywood is
Pink's yeah it's the worst they they are
goddamned wizards horrific
I remember horrific coming like moving
here you do and you like
that spot there's outline again you get
one of those hot dogs who went all the
hot dog yeah you're into hot dogs no
actually I feel like you actually why I
didn't win you're like this is amazing
and then well then you take then you
take another bite you're like no I I
just I just hype myself on it's taking
me yeah but listen [ __ ] us that place is
crowded every goddamn night every day no
it's about cooking outdoors to having
that open window was he walked by you
could see them cooking the hot dogs I
went in there and the buns were pink the
buns were yellow mmm the chili was
god-awful you know what the problem is
with god-awful the real problem for me
is always gonna be that I've had real
New York hotdog snap when you bite that
bad breath yeah you know there's those
type of hot dogs that they what they
were making the buns were perfect that
they had like a lens go so far with
burgers dude no amazing but but there's
something about when you snap into one
of those and you taste a real fresh real
delicious hot dog tasted regular
[ __ ] hot dogs
they just don't fly anymore hot dogs you
know alcohol isn't some sort of a beef
with fans about that it's a bunch of
dogs
it's got off it's like you read no wheel
from American Airlines you think you're
poisoning yourself every time I get the
old meal from America and I'm like am i
[ __ ] poison those Dodger dogs are so
[ __ ] bad they're horrible I don't give
a [ __ ] what anybody says when I was in
the US from junior year what's that word
excoriates he excoriates the Dodger dog
implores Rams to serve better beef what
is that word have you ever seen that
word Wow
however you are word wizard of Google my
junior year in high school mr.
Hildebrand took us to the [ __ ] sad
brat place just to take us through a
little walk
you know because well his job was to do
was to every month to show us
in Korea yeah these and we went to this
this hotdog thing that I don't like we
had to take a bus down there have you
ever seen that
no okay so there's four Puerto Ricans
and about boobs and they got yellow
suits on and they got those boots on
okay and there's a [ __ ] you know when
you work on a construction site and you
throw the sheetrock in the tube and the
tube goes down to the first floor into
the dumpster okay so there's a tube like
that and then there's this for Puerto
Ricans were brewing and then six Porto
Ricans with bags of 80 pounds of 90
pound salt this is back in 1980 okay
okay you know 90 pounds and there's
balance of 90 pounds and everyone
somehow the light turns red and this
thing just body parts start falling
heads shoulders I ball you just see and
then these guys the other Puerto Ricans
break the bags of salt and put them on
this [ __ ] that's falling like it's
nonstop BAM and these guys sweep that
into a [ __ ] hole and that's how the
hot dog gets but it's everything it's
the leg the hoof the arm you know we
think what happens to a leg when
somebody gets into a car it's on the 4
or 5 we think happens to the leg you
think they take it home [ __ ] no they
call Hormel first they go home Mel we
got a black leg for you it's about 300
pounds I will call you back in five
minutes then they call White Castle
listen we got a deal for you then they
hang up with him
and they collagens and they cost a comes
they send that leg [ __ ] legs weighs
300 pounds you think they just put that
leg away [ __ ] could you imagine if they
found out that people was we're grinding
up people they found the morgue and he
had a friend a supermarket got all the
money so at night he'd go kill him in
the supermarket and put him in the meat
grinder and the next day people come in
and put that meat what the [ __ ] were you
eating what do you think was left over
in a couple of his murders he had a guy
that all the money for [ __ ] he was
like wasn't he drowned
draining people training people training
training people the other guy from the
Gambino's owned the chain of
supermarkets you know this guy from the
camera the other guy from the Gambino's
owned great web great white auto immune
queens is [ __ ] they have those people
that balance your tires you [ __ ] well
that legit businesses I was a good way
to declare income the other guy had the
guy that the heavy guy Conti is
something that guy was a known heroin
dealer he was on the board of director
of noose bombs of a supermarket let me
think what this [ __ ] did they
had about 30 reps per head about 30
supermarkets in the Jersey area and one
day he just called local 202 carpenters
and said to me a favor go to every
supermarket a denial so every
supermarket had an aisle that whatever
they took went directly to the mom whoa
so they had 13 supermarkets with like
Aisle number five wasn't really on
number five nobody know about number
five so whatever was bought in that
aisle that cash went upstairs for 13
supermarkets on a daily basis then we
just go into a supermarket and add two
lanes and go we don't even don't worry
about those two legs Wow how [ __ ]
bizarre is that yeah yeah just it's
crazy that the FBI
all the people the various law
enforcement organizations figured out a
way to crack that and break it down they
cracked it after they've made 10 million
mmm then they cracked it you know losing
studio city bro who I just met him at
this coffee shop about three months ago
and I talk to him all the time and I'm
about to sick him loose on people sick
of lumps on people who the last
Godfather in this country was a guy by
the name of Joe something big fat guy he
came out and he may never be shut up he
was [ __ ] genius Joe came out of jail
I mean everybody shut the social clubs
everybody had to have a job everybody
had to have a job no drugs everybody
stuck to it they were doing phenomenal
he was doing phenomenal Joe Massino but
somebody was shaking down a restaurant
and he went in there and they were givin
him twenty thousand a week for security
so they couldn't figure out how to get
Massino because he wasn't doing anything
outside and they got this forensic
accountant to go in there and they shut
down the mob this guy well this guy
retired was in [ __ ] Studio City we
were talkin the one day goes for a
thousand bucks somebody gives you a hard
time you have the right to go in there
and look at their books he goes don't
bring though he's [ __ ] white it is
from Hollywood bring me because I'll
find everything in there plus I'll make
them a deal if they don't pay you I
called my friends at the [ __ ] IRS and
I'll have him here within a day looking
through you [ __ ] so we're ready to
sick [ __ ] I got one guy I'm
ready to stick him on he keeps telling
me oh we haven't made any money keep it
up keep it up cuz I'm gonna SiC this
little [ __ ] and this guy's one of
those he's not even Jewish he's just
crazy and white but for a thousand bucks
he'll go in there and he was the same
guy that brought down thousands of
people for the FBI when they can't
figure you out forensic [ __ ] SIA
accounting you're done the math better
add up jack Jesus Christ Oh
so anybody gives you guys a hard time we
don't know we haven't sold a lot of them
thousand bucks and he'll go in there
he's [ __ ] when you look at him he's
one of those white dudes that did 30
years in the Marines that he's pretty
serious he goes I'll rip them [ __ ]
open for you oh I'll find every dime and
then I'll make them an offer they can't
refuse but they got three days to give
you a check for the onion whatever or we
contact our buddies on the IRS and I
have me in 24 hours for looking you
[ __ ] until they find something cool
is that true can you really do that oh
no the [ __ ] you call the IRS and go hey
man watch [ __ ] [ __ ] wait till you
see the end of the year with all these
people who've been talking [ __ ] about
Trump you think Kathy Griffin's then I
got getting her ass than anybody else
you watch I don't trust Trump when it
comes to something like that I'm not
saying he's a bad dude or anything like
that what I'm saying is trouble follows
dude you really don't want to mess with
I believe that I believe that if people
want to put pressure on you they could
get you to the IRS I think agencies have
been doing it for years
I shouldn't even ask what did you guys
think of this charlottesville stuff his
reaction to it I think he's just a big
failure man I mean what was it what did
you feel like he fumbled on what I
thought was like two levels like so
there's the there's the leadership like
presidential level right where you go
like this is the office that we look to
and then there's like the person so I
think he's it's weird how he makes you
know everything is about him and and he
even started one of those press
conferences and it went into like how
the economy is doing so like I think
it's hard to view that dude morally as
somebody that you're I don't know you
know that you would enjoy being around
as a person and then I get I actually I
get what he was trying to do I do - with
his criticizing and Tifa and stuff like
I I you know I get but like it's the
lack of savviness is even maybe more
like that in not knowing like this is a
time where you do this and not that
that's also something you're like wow
like he just just feels like it's he's
totally unfit for the job in my opinion
well I also feel like when you're the
when you're the president the workload
must be impossible to imagine before you
get in there
and once you get in there you're dealing
with all these pressures all the
super important decisions in all these
different areas and then some new [ __ ]
comes up I really think I'm not even
seen this as a critical of like I don't
like him I really think he is and the
only a few other people can experience
this is truly like holy [ __ ] with what
this job entails I think so too I think
it's really like one of those things
where he's like wow and you can see that
he's constantly like he always refers to
the campaign still always any converse
as you'll talk about like I beat those
guys and yeah because I think that's the
part that he enjoyed he import' enjoyed
the competition whole days of the
campaign and I think like and then you
know he's always bringing up like oh the
new deck but the Dow was setting records
for months and months and months but
like he'll still you know tweets will be
about that or interviews me about that
he can't not make a conversation a
statement with I think talking there
probably is a connection though between
the Dow being up and him being in office
and people thinking that he's friendly
to business markets love it there's
definitely no doubt about that but
there's also no doubt that unemployment
was at record lows and setting records
before yeah and the Dow has been
breaking has been on an upswing for
years now isn't that how it always is
like presidents always come in and take
advantage of the upward like there's
like the course right but the economy
does come in these ebbs and flows it
does come in as and flows in the market
inevitably at least in the history of it
always comes back always comes back you
know if you even if you stayed through
like Black Monday if you the market
still eventually comes back I'm too
stupid to understand that I'm too stupid
to get the market you know no no I mean
I am in the sense that I'm not really
interested in pursuing those lines of
thought I get that that's different
my brain is just like yeah this seems
like a pot of [ __ ] to me I gotta get out
of here if I believe this I don't know
anything that happened stock market
strange no no no I know it some white
supremacist for somebody shows oh sure
right I don't pay attention yeah how did
disconnect myself
I don't watch world my crew photo shoot
yeah they finished is that sprained that
makes everybody gay that they put on
frog
they're now using a j.crew like you know
Ambercrombie and Fitch does yeah as you
walk in and they hit you with that that
gay frog spray you know I'm talking
about no it makes you gay so a bunch of
dudes got crazy tattooed swastikas on
themselves took their shirts off they're
all walking around with citronella
candles that they got from like a
hardware store that was the stupidest
part of it all that can't they had like
torches but they were walking on the
street with like come on you guys are
walking around with lon torches they're
[ __ ] didn't even make the
Frankenstein walk we get the [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] mosquito repellents ooh
[ __ ] listen dogs I tell you what this is
you know what man I have so many things
on my plate I had to stop watching and
I'm gonna tell you something else I had
to sit my wife down like a man and tell
her CS NBC was not a lot of the house no
more my wife is very political and how
to cut her off like I can't have it it
gets overwhelming I can't happen yeah
well you know we would go out to dinner
and somebody would bring some up and I
had a kicker under the table and I've
know bad let's not I'm not talking about
that [ __ ] yeah you know how you hear
that expression more than you know as a
kid where people were like never bring
up politics or religion right and as a
kid you're like I don't understand why
that but this is I feel like the age
where it becomes the most clear and and
at the time where you're like oh I told
like we can actually probably have a
good time if no one talks about these
and it always comes up guys you can't
see four people talk for five minutes
about anything without somebody bringing
some not political yeah and you know
what at the end of the week Dawg you
still gotta get up and go to work you
still got to get up with groceries yes
they're gonna wipe your ass yeah all
this knowledge and gops and SLDS I grew
up in Hudson County New Jersey which
comes in to the Cook County Illinois
yeah so I learned about politics and a
micro what's a small microcosm yeah yeah
and it's a horrible thing I benefited
from it I had no show jobs I had a trip
down see no jobs yeah I had a no-show
job at Horace Mann school when I was a
kid I'm going there once a week and pick
up a
I can laugh at the old janitors I didn't
never moved the desk no I'm a carmine
got me the job got arrested so but it's
I saw the level they're never interested
in me I was like these people [ __ ]
pukes they're [ __ ] pukes with suits
on yeah you know before you guys are
talking about taxpayer payer money I
want to see the addendum for the 12
[ __ ] idiots that sit there with suits
that are old and white and they sit
there and huh you know more hours to
make a decision that's what my money
goes yeah you know you don't know about
bureaucracy till my mother died that's
when I learned about bureaucracy anaphor
at 15 that's why I don't like it because
my mother died I couldn't even collect
Social Security without coming up with
92 sheets of paper yeah that's a [ __ ]
Social Security [ __ ] number that's a
[ __ ] name and that's when she died
and that's a death certificate give me
my [ __ ] money
oh no oh no it's another letter and
another meeting and you paid your taxes
you paid for this this is your [ __ ]
hard-earned money that's when you learn
that it's all [ __ ] this is all
[ __ ] we are taxed you know of you in
four years your kids gonna come tea and
go Daddy
or your daughter's gonna come tea and go
up I want to play basketball you take
them down there it they charge you 85 to
sign up 32 for this shirt which really
is worth [ __ ] $8 on the [ __ ] in
the black market
and then you got to pay the sneakers
which are $100 when I was a kid drunk
Texas below I went to Union City I told
him I want to play basketball they put
you on a team they give you a shirt and
you play it every week for free it
didn't cost you anything
look at the [ __ ] I don't even know
about taxes or anything Joe all I know
about is when I go buy a plane ticket
and I look at those prices and I go what
about the family or two that isn't doing
that well yeah what about the [ __ ] if
I was if I was really for tax or I'm I
have felonies I can't vote so I don't
even let that thing go on my mind what
about the 15 hours I got to pay for
parking when I go to a UFC event yeah
what about the [ __ ] 184 dollars for a
[ __ ] Laker ticket
a hundred hours for a [ __ ] baseball
ticket when does it end that's what I'm
concerned about I don't give a [ __ ]
about anything else I want them to bomb
[ __ ] Isis now today but everything
else for me applies to the American
family yeah that the American family
does not stand a chance in this country
no more if your wife works and you have
to pay day care what are you bringing
home what are you clearing after daycare
right somebody was telling me for summer
camp in Studio City it's two hundred a
week that's eight hundred a month for
the average person what's the average
person making this [ __ ] country Joe
Rogan so your taxes again used for [ __ ]
my taxes are getting used for [ __ ] [ __ ]
because they're not going to where
they're supposed to go 800 a month is
like what is that like nine thousand
ninety six hundred a year that's a lot
of money but foot [ __ ] and the girl
was telling me that her son has to
volunteer and help other kids to get
that rate you know city and I just was
telling them kindergarten at monarch is
thirty thirty four thousand dollars what
is it in the valley and you know don't
even mind the other two with his
denzel's daughter went to school oh my
god oh my and by the way we're talking
about all this like it's a big deal if
we were living in Manhattan don't be a
bargain bargain that's what I would like
to think about politics I think about
people who are [ __ ] struggling that
have two children and they can't go to a
Dodger game how many [ __ ] baseball
games as a kid right I can't tell you
how many I went to as a kid yeah yeah
but these families cannot afford a
Dodger game well I'm a [ __ ] Savage
my uncle loves baseball he's an old man
I would go to Costco and for $50 I get
two tickets two hotdogs two sodas in a
parking spot I don't care about the
[ __ ] game I take can be 74 once magic
took over the Dodgers they don't give
you that deal no more you know it seems
like it's like if you have a giant
population like we do in LA and
something like a Dodger ticket or
something even though it's a giant
number of people yeah it's still a small
percent
edge of this huge population I guess
they just realize anybody does this
realize is you just jack it up higher
you're gonna get a smaller percentage
people but they're still enough people
right exactly like why would we do that
right let's do that let's just make more
and then if you you know how it is when
you go to a theater or something like
that yeah it's got to be twice that if
you're is there some sort of a baseball
game or something like that
or one of those huge stadiums think
about all the people gonna have to get
paid all the people that are working
there while you're working they're like
just a giant staff of humans that have
to keep that thing running smooth you
know what about the American family that
flies I'm also gonna bring a water it's
four dollars and fifty cents for a
bottle of water
damn is their charging I thought the
water was free give you a cup of water
no a couple water winneth and then when
you go through tsa you can't bring the
water through you can't but you can you
can buy water on the other side there's
not if Joe Rogan you just barely getting
by yeah and you have three [ __ ] kids
and it's three dollars a [ __ ] water
yeah I mean that's the [ __ ] that as
always certainly [ __ ] break small guy
the [ __ ] guy that wants to take the
guy that works he's divorced he pays
child support he wants to take his kid
to a Dodger game and for him together
ticket he's gonna say with gangbangers
and wear a helmet and the [ __ ] money
guard [ __ ] suit yeah and you know you
smoke pot now at Dodger Stadium really
there's a little section supposedly that
you walk to the left and people's
parking over there is that true just do
it man if anybody would let it go it's
LA right yeah it's got more tolerance
for weed than LA yeah always did you see
that video I don't know where the [ __ ]
had happened I think it was on the
Instagram feed clown in the homie I
don't know if you know that one they
always have some fun stuff up there but
there's a big giant white guy this black
cop beats the [ __ ] out of him tasers him
beats the [ __ ] out of him with a club
and then eventually they tasered him
from behind another guy got on me felm
banged his head off the ground and the
whole time the guy was saying like I am
NOT fighting you I'm not fighting you
and they just beaten on him with this
[ __ ] poll that job and I've said it a
million times is not for everybody
and it's one of the most difficult
[ __ ] jobs of the world being cop yep
yeah and what we're seeing when we're
seeing like
that guy that shot that woman in the
alley this guy getting beat up by this
metal pipe of Baltimore cops
man [ __ ] evidence and drugs how long
you know michoacán 20 years I did time
though they use a verb ever ever haven't
heard me say some crazy [ __ ] don't crazy
[ __ ] but you've never heard me say the
word Pig yeah no I have the most respect
for police officers it's a small
percentage of people a stressful job but
something's going on now it's not just
stressful
what about two days ago there's nine
minutes with the gun to the black couple
why he was getting his license and they
kept saying please put the gun away and
the guy held the gun there is sure and
then I love when if they shoot a black
person they just get like the black da
they go up there saying well we looked
this year they beat up that black
metonic kid downtown eight cops to beat
up a black [ __ ] and then the [ __ ]
kid died and they said it's the [ __ ]
black kids fault he's [ __ ] [ __ ]
eight cops on top of them beating them
but this goes on constantly and you know
what's gonna happen and you [ __ ] know
what's gonna happen you know exactly
what's kind of [ __ ] happen
two or three years from now all it takes
is three angry black guys three angry
black guys with a surplus to spread the
word it was done with the Black Panthers
it was done fee is three and a
back-slapping black guys and they're
gonna [ __ ] start going around in
cities and saying there's a fire and
when all these cops show up they're
gonna be on rubes and they're gonna open
up on them this is gonna happen in
American cities so don't [ __ ] tell me
this is gonna happen yeah three black
guys that went to the service that got
weapons like I told you
unless you're [ __ ] you can't get
weapons today I get I get you whatever
the [ __ ] you want and something I get
you something an hour an hour I'll get
you something to go fight I believe you
so never mind assault rifles and [ __ ]
like that
right that's all you need is five
assault rifles and say that a woman is
getting raped at the end of [ __ ]
Cherokee Street and wait for 20 cops to
come and open up on them dogs all
headshots headshot some leg shots that's
gonna happen eventually because this
cannot continue
this cannot continue I think most people
that become cops
have a very difficult time doing it I
think for some people it's unmanageable
and I think if you think about all the
interactions that all the police
officers have with all the people all
day long all across the country the vast
majority of it is inconsequential it's
people traffic violations little things
here and there but there's going to be a
percentage
what is that percentage is it even 1% I
don't know what it is but if that 1%
gets online we focus on that 1% so
whether it's that guy planting drugs in
Baltimore or these guys beating up this
giant white guy that was giant but he
wasn't threatening them in any way just
didn't want these guys like [ __ ]
danger in them yeah and I think there's
just way too few people that are capable
of navigating the wall the waters of
that kind of job I think that kind of
job is almost it's almost as bad or as
difficult rather as being in the
military your life is on on the line
you're at risk all the time constantly
you know and people call you a cop
apologist if you looked at it like that
listen man if the [ __ ] goes down
someone's breaking into your house
you're calling the cops man ok that's
what they're here for and to pretend
that you don't need them is your crate
wokai maybe someday we won't but right
now you need cops for sure and then you
definitely need each other they need
cops too and they know it and they and
they see it more than you do because
they're the ones who responds to murders
and armed robberies and rapes
they're the ones who have to show up and
handle car accidents on the highway with
I mean how much special training do they
have it they get to deal with bodies
that are torn apart [ __ ] how much
special training no I know I'm not sure
I'm not sure you could even adequately
train a person these some people can
handle it period but there's some people
they see some dark [ __ ] and they just
don't recover and then you ask those
people just hello but I also think that
they should train the cops a little more
I see a lot I don't think you have the
money I say I agree with you I agree
with you I see a lot of dumb [ __ ] in LA
bro you know times you're on Hollywood
Boulevard bumper to bumper and you go to
see what it is and it's a [ __ ] cop
double-parked giving a homeless guy a
hard time yeah pull the cop in you pull
the car and you [ __ ] scumbag can you
tell it's four o'clock in this [ __ ]
traffic they don't care they don't give
a [ __ ] you know once I yelled one day I
yell from the car and they looked at me
I yell really guys 8:00 in the morning
double [ __ ] parked really no [ __ ]
genius here and this smoke coming out
his mouth while he screaming you want to
give me a ticket when we go to court
we'll talk about and now we all got
phones now we all got [ __ ] phones and
videos no [ __ ] that's what's very
dangerous is these laws against people
filming cops while they're doing [ __ ]
like you can't have that no is that
really a lot of them yes it is there are
several places where it is illegal to
film cops while they're doing things Wow
fine it's federally it's not I mean I
know for sure the police have tried to
tell people it's not but I'm pretty sure
my spread and fake news it's like oh no
it's like I know that they can let's
find out at this pace
are there places where it's illegal to
film the cops I know they can tell you
like if there's a situation going down I
felt like I was lying eyes are that that
you can they can tell you that they need
a certain I got a bit of space but I
don't think they can tell you to stop
filming hmm that's interesting we should
go to Vegas and there was altercation
and there were these [ __ ] smart kids
and the cops kept telling them they had
to get off and they would take they
would shooting the cops and tell them
that it was there right here we go
taking photographs and videos of things
that are plainly visible in public
spaces is a constitutional right and
that includes police and other
government officials carrying out their
duties however there is a widespread and
continuing pattern of law enforcement
officers ordering people to stop taking
photographs or video in public places
and harassing detaining and arresting
those who fail to comply the right of
citizens to record the police is a
critical check and balance it creates an
independent record of what took place in
the in a particular incident ok well
that that's so that seems like maybe
what I was reading was about people that
got arrested for it so the cops were
arresting them for but either even
though it's not really illegal I mean
they can still arrest you for a lot of
things then you get a court in them
figure out the arrests so if a cop
arrests you for not listening to him so
if your if say if a cop is arresting
someone and you're filming it because
he's kicking this guy's ass and you
start filming it and the cop says if you
do not put that camera down I will
arrest you and they can still arrest you
they could say you're obstructing
justice or right well the reason they
would say not to turn the cameras off
who's doing something wrong well so I
got you there right it's like [ __ ]
hard to stay on the right path
and not go straight Dirty Harry if some
guys trying to kill you and you're
you're you know you're involved in some
situation and then you see people
filming it - [ __ ] man I wouldn't want to
navigate any of the [ __ ] that cops have
to go through on a daily basis all me
neither me neither but they also have to
they gotta clean it up a little bit and
when they do something wrong and we
watch it on film they can't tell us that
the cop was justified to do something
that was a lot of [ __ ] calm that I mean
there was 37 murders in Chicago
you know and those places a high level
but there's a lot of times I've seen
cops act a little too much for what the
situation in cost well I grew up in
Jersey what cops come and they talk to
you they ask you they separate you and
they determine if this was even worth
the [ __ ] angle right these guys today
they'll come in even if we do something
at the store they'll come in the store
and investigate him for what would you
do
go [ __ ] chase him chase some [ __ ]
bank robber the day after 9/11 I pulled
into [ __ ] 7-eleven and a guy had
pulled over the line okay you know his
car pulled over the line so my car was
over the line
the guy next to me in the hall cause I
pulled in I was six inches over a
handicapped thing on the blue line yeah
cut made a u-turn and came and gave me a
$458 talk I understood I was wrong but
with this we just blow up the World
Trade Center yeah you ain't got nothing
better to do you know I see [ __ ]
kinky [ __ ] all the [ __ ] time if I'm
not involved so it's got nothing to do
with me part of the problem is cops
there's a statistic number that they
have to reach right like if they believe
that certain amount of traffic
violations taking place in LA there's a
strong influence on those guys to write
a certain amount of tickets whether you
call it a quota anymore because I think
those things are Shawn they say they
don't have a quota but they have
something if there's there's some
barrier there out there yeah there's
some severe incentive and if you don't
meet the numbers that they expect and
they in in some way shape or form think
you're not addressing some of the crimes
that are being committed out there I'm
sure you get a hard time for it listen
brother when I got arrested in 87 that
Detective that [ __ ] [ __ ] from
Boulder who I liked you know he got me
for four years and he thought he was
[ __ ] what we know like going home you
know like when they were sitting when
they locked up Gotti the Teflon Don he
loved you know what are you talking
about you could have got me for 22 years
you done your homework that couple of
dollars just a little bit he I would
have done 23 years how many times I sat
next time of the preliminary hearing and
I'm like I hope this dude don't
recognize me because yeah come to talk
to me about something else the same
[ __ ] cop a year earlier put it
together and that would have got me more
in the kidnapping so every time I saw
this cop I would sit there at the end I
would just call him like a big dope
because he was six foot four with the
big chest with the bulletproof your
dummy it's like that [ __ ] kid a
couple weeks ago that pushed that
[ __ ] little Mexican hot dog cart
you'll never hear from him again
little Argentinian dude that pushed that
little dope Mexican dude with it with
the fruit cart Jesus Christ Joe Rogan
watch lions attacking a monkey but you
haven't seen of something that way a
couple of weeks ago with some poor
little Mexican do with selling hot dogs
on the corner and some [ __ ] little he
thought he was one of those dudes with
the skinny jeans with a Guns and Roses
shirt him and his fat white ugly [ __ ]
girlfriend went up to the dude and told
him to move
you never saw this they told them to
move the man harasses food vendor
flipping oh my god Joe Rogan huh
look at this [ __ ] jerk-off looking
with a dog you could tell you the
[ __ ] [ __ ] what happened he told to
move little speck kid turns out of this
camera we move it why because he's
[ __ ] he's a skinny jean guy with that
dirty filthy white animal of a
girlfriend look at him so he wants to be
a tough guy with his fidel beard
watch what happens though
but look at the Mexican before he
[ __ ] threw that red pepper right his
[ __ ] face look this is what I saw
white people did what we're calling the
police
[Music]
that dude had to pick up and move let me
tell you what those could you see those
carts with the umbrellas haven't you
noticed a lot more of those carts that
have the rainbow umbrella Tom Segura
I've seen a few you know why
no at the cartel really remember years
ago when you first moved to LA that was
star maps
what's going on here at the rest of it
Jamie guy takes off his shirt do they
get in a fight after this no he [ __ ]
threw the pepper riders face the [ __ ]
hot pepper tremendous you guys just took
his shirt off yeah see because he to
pepper in his face little foot he's
still hanging out like right there it's
weird because they took the cops are
gonna come people came to help this
little Mexican dude but that dude had to
leave town with his fat [ __ ]
disgusting filthy girlfriend the tight
jeans because you know runs those things
the cartel that's why you see so many
more was his B's didn't like it they
just didn't wanna make cause it's like
Silver Lake and he's special
he's a white dude with a skinny [ __ ]
jeans a little [ __ ] [ __ ] fidel beard
you know what I've noticed man there's a
lot of people that think that it's okay
to be aggressive because they're in the
right but they come with a dog dog ain't
nothing gonna go down that's a [ __ ]
that dude was a [ __ ] that poor kid let
me tell you something the cartel brings
the code up and fruit they chop up the
fruit then they sell the fruit they
don't make a don't make a loss they have
these new umbrellas everywhere and they
have them even across the street from
each other they don't sell drugs that's
what they make the cash drop offs
I've had people see them all away from
San Diego all the way the [ __ ]
receiver they're all on the main strips
and they're all confused that's why
they're around she's DEA don't catch
them they don't drop off drugs they just
drop off an envelope with a number on it
number a 52 that's rude you're Rogen's
number and then some guy comes that day
and picks up all the envelopes and goes
right to ends to need and that's the end
of the day when we first got here with
star maps yeah and what was they turned
out to be a Spanish prostitution ring
was it really [ __ ] yeah they were
[ __ ] those little Mexican kids up the
airs they jumped the wall to stretch the
muffler out some white dukkha [ __ ]
mini Elavon I gotta pee I'm trying to
hold the same
you didn't know that no no I didn't know
that that star maps I even made a movie
about it what star maps you really went
out there with the title what's the
weight they made a movie about it yeah
and this was what you could bro
the tagline down there if you can read
it Tom yeah Carlos wants to be an actor
but his father
Pepe wants him to work in the family
business that is male prostitution
Carlos decides that he will be one of
his father's boys until he can what in
the [ __ ] man star max I had no idea 1997
that's good that's so nuts no idea
that's for people that don't know that's
the people that used they sold maps to
celebrity homes right that was the world
a sunset when you first got here in 98
there was a thousand of those mooks on
Sunset [ __ ] you know yeah yeah and
Hollywood right yeah and they're still
out there they still are but at which is
less Hoenn is involved with that well no
I don't see the star I see the star vans
I don't see the star maps I don't see
the [ __ ] so much better what are you
gonna do with our lives that's the thing
where does it all go man a thousand
podcast now it's changed [ __ ] society
you [ __ ] a changed us they've changed
us for sure it's uh you tap in all the
people thing although if you leave that
on the conversations you've had with
those people you know how much that
would you ever have if it wasn't for
doing your podcast you know it changes
you change the way you think of things
it changes me for sure it changed a lot
of the way I think of things because I
get any chance to sit down with you over
hours and hours uninterrupted no phone
calls no messages no text messages
to be able to do that on a regular basis
you get to know people in a like a way
different way you don't really get a
chance to do that with each other that
often you know to sit down and just have
no distractions just you and a friend
having a conversation laughing talk and
[ __ ] about things well the cool thing is
that's the experience people are getting
listening to it yeah that's why you know
how much time how many times have we
been on the road and we went to a diner
afterwards and we were laughing
literally until we in tears
yeah falling down like we were doing
podcast it was just nobody listening
don't lecture crying and laughing you
know like the three of us it's some
[ __ ] strange Nashville it's I
understand totally is what happened
today it's the same thing exactly
exactly exactly not so cool to replicate
there's left in that joint over there
shout out to LA speed weed momentum and
keep it keeping it strong you know what
they gotta do though they gotta be
careful with these [ __ ] things they
give you these feeling this it's made
out of actual glass the thing that the
weed comes in and breaks in your pocket
oh that's no good yeah that's not good
this one is superior like when you go to
a plastic at a hotel like a finds and
they give you glasses and then there's
two glasses by the sink like what the
[ __ ] those pretentious weed guys yeah oh
man well it's clearly an indica probably
the South American strain like I micro
dosed huh the other side it might be BC
it might be BC yes I'm pretty sure
pretty sure it's like maybe maybe
Seattle maybe Seattle no it's Northwest
man just Northwest it's like basically
the good stuff Joe we [ __ ]
adrenaline wow I forgot there's a show
tonight
yeah I'm gonna forget a lot of [ __ ]
along the way yeah I feel like it's CPM
we talked about some [ __ ] earlier that
was the funniest [ __ ] ever said in my
life
but if anybody asked me like how's the
podcast today oh dude Joey Diaz went on
a rant it was the funniest [ __ ] thing
I ever heard in my life
then he go what is it about ago couldn't
die ya know I also couldn't tell you
what the last thing we talked about is
whatever is important something
important these things change us man I
know your your podcast changing you Joey
you know it's can it's connecting you
with those people that like to come out
to see you in a way that nothing else
has ever had before you know no the
biggest thing about the podcast is keeps
me in check it keeps up in Jack you
substance check yeah we gotta stick to
what we say yeah we gotta preach what we
talk about you know accuses in check man
yeah there's no more we got somebody
watching this now that you know so it's
pretty [ __ ] interesting to me it does
keep being checked but it also it's it's
um ultimately satisfying to you you know
to just stay in check you know it's like
think about what you're doing say say
things that are as accurate as you
possibly know be honest about how you
know how you're thinking about these
things like where you're drawing your
conclusions from totally people don't
have a chance to do that that often they
don't have to be accountable for their
own thoughts you know not not to the
level of like someone who is hosting a
podcast or someone who's constantly
being reviewed by people you know and
people do hold you accountable to do
they do and that's why I like a bus they
should if I get to do a periscope in the
morning and I tell people I'm gonna do
jitsu today I get 20 tweets sent in
there yeah I wasn't what did you learn I
didn't go because are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah do you guys listen bro let me tell
you something the doctor told my mother
to stop drinking she's not drinking and
11 days later she was dead that's why I
believe you always got to have a shot at
something I'm talking about [ __ ]
drinking a bottle at night I'm not a big
believer in anecdotal evidence unless it
benefits me so in that case one
two notes ain't gonna kill nobody you
were saying doctors say do this cyka
lemme [ __ ] you good sir
when you drink these things cause that's
nothing
I love the white dudes I love crazy
white people do you like I don't like
these Alex oh you like nice white people
they drive me with but what about
Charlottesville kind of crazy white
people like where do you draw the line I
like white people who bring a bottle of
bourbon but the most important thing is
they bring a bag guys cuz they are you
[ __ ] with the ice okay yeah when the
white dude shows up with a bag ice
that's a man of class style is
sophisticated don't put in the freezer
leave it right there
that means they drop one ice cube in
there every 20 minutes and they got a
time that's not the whole thing
yeah it's the [ __ ] ice yeah I totally
agreement if you go over his dudes house
and he's got a walk-in humidor filled
with cigars do you go huh yeah Milo what
the [ __ ] are you doing man what are you
doing with your time you got a walk-in
humidor
I feel like aged matches up with cigars
in a way that few things do like an old
dude with a cigar is like I want to hang
out with him I'm gonna have the drink I
want to hear what he has to say yeah
like a 22 year old what's ago I'm like
get the [ __ ] out of here you can't
you're like white t-shirt with the
leather vest
you know coolest moment look cool
smoking cigar Tony Soprano oh yeah I
need the [ __ ] cigar you know why I
bet James Gandolfini really enjoyed
smoking a cigar
so he's like actually enjoying the cigar
while he's acting like he's enjoying
several enjoys at your room you want me
to tell you something that's the first
guy I could say that like door a couple
weeks ago I went back to my hotel room
the [ __ ] original guy the way it was
on with Steve McQueen and I think
I forgot do you forget your rodent mmm
look I get tears in my eyes he's in the
dumpster with that [ __ ] after the thing
tripped him over and she's [ __ ]
telling them all he's like well we
should just break ways and she's like
well obviously you can't get over me
having sex with somebody else that
you're a mental [ __ ] oh and Steve
McQueen bro he just grabbed her by the
hand you find then he goes back to the
hotel he shoots all those [ __ ]
rednecks oh we forget how bad Steve
McQueen we look at him look at this
[ __ ] look at this [ __ ] man of a
man that he was there's there's my man
salaat so from the Godfather watch Steve
McQueen with a [ __ ] suit on this is
1973 dog he's so smooth this is not the
scene you gotta put on the scene is when
he beats up Ali MacGraw and she thought
it was acting and he just liveth he
breathed pretty much smack the [ __ ] out
of her she didn't know but he would
smack the [ __ ] outta every other day for
some reason or another he was like he
was like you know you gotta kick out
once a day somewhere in the back and the
stomach shut the [ __ ] this woman was
number one look at the natural beauty on
this [ __ ] woman and look at this
blonde savage of a man look at them well
Steve McQueen gets out of the car and he
just starts walking in front of the car
does he smack her after this watch he
was no [ __ ] he had two beautiful alright
look at him with his black suit on he's
furious fine hair I'd wear my hair like
that yes I work me too like my head
start to fall I upper grays igloo I
figured out the time you don't wanna
lose your phrasing a little more it
won't go nowhere now she's getting out
of the car she looks upset
very emotional yeah a year is this 72 I
was nine I want to see this the first
weekend
my mother goes what you get to see Steve
McQueen are you [ __ ] crazy Wow
oh Jesus Christ oh dude he's hitting
there for real she didn't know she's
gonna hit she didn't know oh my god [ __ ]
man
Jesus man euros last time you saw it you
got to see this [ __ ] and if you really
want to see a beatin you gotta pull out
the longest yard with Burt Reynolds in
the beginning when he grabs him by the
throat and hits her with the bottle of
something
this is Burt we watch it here but this
this is [ __ ] up because this is crazy
you you know he's really hitting her
yeah he told you wanted her it's like
when Sean Penn did that close range with
with whatever yeah and he kept shooting
a gun and finally Sean Pangos give me
the gun cuz you're not reacting the
right way you're not being scared so he
shot a real gun at Christopher Walken
Christopher Walken talks about it all
the time
look at this [ __ ] Savage go knows the
movie oposition Jesus Christ Jesus
Christ
it's amazing what forty years has done
yeah people used to be be a lot how
beautiful she was us beauty ever see I'm
splitting man look at his body but this
guy was not juicing this guy is [ __ ]
nuts
you all-american son of a [ __ ] yeah
this is like a soap opera from Mexico
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is a [ __ ] soap opera from Mexico
bro totally is so remember the 70s
everybody had booze net and TV everybody
Leila everybody's house had booze
Nutella Mira miss soy Burt Reynolds yeah
yeah well
well
so hostile oh my god she bit him
oh she threw some [ __ ] at them this is a
Mexican soap opera sorry Oh fake slapped
that was a real throw that was a real
throw that throw the ground seems super
real that would hurt your hip that's a
hard floor didn't even give her a
cushion man like look at what's going on
yeah there was an actress an entire
revolution yeah would you let Burt
Reynolds throw you to the ground no [ __ ]
no no not that year dude getting thrown
now hurts that [ __ ] hurts like she just
ricocheted off the ground a hundred
percent that wasn't a stunt person yeah
geez jerk off to this stuff weird
question out dog gets into his car super
weird
he starts it up Joe Rogan Joe Rogan you
ready for this he gets in his [ __ ]
without and begins he starts it up and
also you're here Saturday night
[ __ ] let it skin it that's awesome to
play that part
oh yeah yeah as soon as then he gets
this class black the car and that's
what's on the rape look at what here we
go Burt Reynolds that [ __ ] box
that's a Maserati it's like an Avanti
it's like oh that's hilarious
whoa the cops should call the cops whoa
that car is so fast oh my god meanwhile
that car handles like total dog [ __ ]
what is it oh no but I mean those cars
back then even the best ones handled
like [ __ ] that thing has skinny tires
a [ __ ] caveman suspension but it
probably did Drive a lot better than
those police cars though police cars
like the worst cars you could drive you
trying to catch somebody they have four
doors you want a car that has two doors
yes no sports car it's got a good
balance and something go around corners
quick with you know like race cars
aren't big long for doors that's a lot
of extra weight nuts yeah I haven't like
a police car like but today they have
police cars today they like they can
make like Mustangs they turn them into
police cars yes God's charger yeah yeah
dude there's some scary cars today when
it comes to like a car pulling you over
like if the cops have that new Dodge
demon have you seen that thing yeah
that's [ __ ] nuts 800 horsepower zero
to 60 in like two seconds like they
can't love it they make sure like I love
it too it doesn't work if it's colder
than 15 degrees out Dubai has the
world's fastest police car who have a
Bugatti oh my god to PI ballin they'd
fallen so strong so boy they're all so
strong I mean if you just respect bond
you gotta forget about cultural
differences you'll respect their ball
Dubai does it well if you if you do it
up even a little bit I don't give a [ __ ]
stop stop making excuses they ball
harder than anybody yeah they have an
indoor ski place that you could have in
the desert
did he an indoors like that reserved
right there no but there was a fight in
Abu Dhabi and we did the weigh-ins in
Dubai that's cool
it was weird man there's much money
there that was innocent against Damien
my oh my yeah and Frankie Edgar versus
BJ Penn to to really have crazy crazy
money oh I think it's off the charts you
know I think I don't think he even
understand oil money you know yeah like
what we make we think we're doing good
yeah these guys like in it's like many
generations of having that kind of cash
it's a different level of cash there for
now yeah big family wealth yeah it gets
passed down that's where the ghee this
is yeah
old white money ain't no strong a gang
in that
they have interior surf places too we
have no surfing it's nuts man you run a
surfboard is that where the government
like will give citizens money that just
want to do anything really yeah yeah my
Dubai I thought so maybe I have it wrong
but my cousin came here to study English
like from Peru so he had a class with a
bunch of people from different countries
I thought he said this classmate from
Dubai would be like everybody wanna go
out on Saturday like it's all good and
would pick people up in like you know
limo buses and he's like hey who's
paying for this oh I got it any [ __ ]
like and then was telling them like he
was like happy you're just gonna pay
this he's like look they've just given
to me man I got spend all this [ __ ] I
don't even know what's a douche Jesus
corns just buying everybody drinks food
going to Vegas like 15 people he's just
in class with yeah nobody balls harder
than them yeah it's pretty out of
control everywhere he goes Ferraris
Bentleys
Lamborghinis there's like ridiculous
there's cars that I feel like it would
be ridiculous to show up well how about
one of those Bentley's that they have or
one of those Bugattis rather that they
have as a police car it's insane isn't
that like two and a half million bucks
yeah so much mile I think look mother
has like six he's got like a whole
friggin white he's like white is right I
got a bunch of cars just give him a few
thought cuz he went so deep so you know
well it's more than you want to pay yes
it's in the 20 plus million dollar range
it's a lot of money man but it's not
something that he's been it's not like
deception no it's just neglect to think
like and it's also like I think and
there is like a truth to this he makes
so much money there's probably a point
when they're like hey it's time to pay
your taxes and you go like alright
here's a check for twenty five million
dollars that's an incredible amount of
money and then they go that's true but
you owe fifty more and he's just like
that's that can't be right
you know I was twenty five million
dollar
yeah like what are you talking about man
he's bought over a hundred luxury cars
in the same dealer and always pays in
cash fifteen million worth of car
congratulate he doesn't drive I like it
good you can sell those they're worth a
lot of money you can get that money -
yeah you know it's um it's it's just
it's it's really interesting in the
amount of money that he's able to
generate yeah you know he's figured out
some pretty incredible [ __ ] he's a great
villain - man oh is it brilliant at it I
mean it's just a brilliant defensive
boxer Oh skill wise off the charts what
I'm saying that guy should get more
credit for what he does as a skilled
businessman and psychological you know
warrior like you should get a lot more
credit for it yeah I think so too I
think there it's it's arguable that you
know he's enjoying it and he enjoys
playing the villain role and joys like
flashing all the money and if he is
really enjoying it like don't you love
that and respect that [ __ ] thing what
is that car that thing looks amazing
a CC XR is that a Khanna sig yeah okay
they say that cone that's a word that
I've never seen I need me I can't say it
I love to that he starts his post with
the amount like to remind people come at
my new car yeah my new 4.8 thank you say
that Koenigsegg Koenigsegg Koenigsegg
Cohen seg Cohen Cohen Cohen Cohen a
Koenigsegg Jesus Christ Koenigsegg CCX
that's a ridiculous name yeah changed
your name the cars dope you were saying
I think so yeah oh yeah I'm in DC both
are working during this fight you were I
had it already now me too
I already booked way in advance now it's
my dad's birthday I'm going a big
birthday celebrate finding out what
happened and then watch you know it
depends man it's a we haven't I don't
know I'm gonna gauge also his interest
in it you know I always try to get home
before I find out anything or watch it
before I find out anything and I always
fail to do so you always cannot give in
I give any temptation
happen Nevada fine now it's hard I go
online let me check real quick yes and
my worth what if they tell me it's a
five-round boring decision you know of a
title fight and this one's gonna be 12
rounds boxing I know it's gonna be it's
it's exciting event it's one of those
like you you'll remember like the
excitement to tune in so I think we were
gonna want to watch it you know Conor
McGregor's a magic person yeah like
legitimately like to get this many
people so hyped up about this fight yeah
it's not just about his performances his
fights it's also about like wanting to
believe that there's a dude you pull it
all off yeah it's like a magic person do
you feel like in the lead-up to the
fight like as we get closer your opinion
on it has changed at all oh yeah I'm a
sucker for a good hype job dude that's
why I'm a good hype man right right yeah
I'm a sucker for believing all that
stupid [ __ ] I thought Gerry Cooney had a
chance against Larry Holmes when I was
in high school yeah I saw Gerry Gerry
Cooney knock out Ken Norton was like he
might have a chance who was the other
white dude that was the great white hope
that I think for Larry Holmes may need
to and he wouldn't make eye contact
no not Chuvalo June of 82 82 oh Galata
was a gallano and you know ya know Gerry
Cooney is the guy that is that the guy
you're thinking of okay yeah that's
Gerry Cooney yeah that's the guy I was
talking about white dude yeah when I was
in high school really who's the white
dude from Bayonne that formerly mo the
Bayonne bleeder
yes weapon yeah he's the guy that they
based the movie Rocky on because they
didn't expect him to survive and he kept
surviving he kept moving forward and
Chuck Wepner was the guy I think that
was one of the inspirations for the
movie Rocky cuz that guy's just kept
plotting forward in Muhammad Ali beat
the [ __ ] out of him but I don't think he
stopped him damn yeah
look at that cracker face man yeah dude
he got dropped there look at that man
Muhammad Ali in his prime was so Magic
what he could do as far as like movement
his ability to like move in and out
slide around a lot of people thought he
was doomed when he was gonna fight Sonny
Liston like there is no [ __ ] way
this kid is in a so much trouble all he
could do is like box around and move and
move fast but Sonny Liston is a murderer
murderous puncher yeah and he got like
he beat the [ __ ] out of Floyd Patterson
it's like the way he would beat those
guys he was like oh Jesus nobody can
stand in front of him like very Rumble
Johnson esque
you know maybe even more so on his power
yeah it was like that it's not taking
place today spot you know it's us it
sucks about not living through an era is
you can never fully appreciate it
totally much as you want to know like I
already know I've had enough lessons
about Ali you know but like you're like
oh man I really wish I would have lived
through it like I already see it now I
became conscious of it now because of
basketball because people are always
always doing this Jordan or LeBron you
know argument this hypothetical and like
you go back and forth but like you real
is the first time I realized there's
people arguing who weren't alive during
that Jordan craziness and I'm like oh
you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about right now you have no idea
what that was like you can pull up any
statistic you want you have what you
know you don't feel that you didn't
watch that dude become a [ __ ] Savage
like a goddamn a you know Spanish
conquistador in [ __ ] the NBA where
you could not believe what a killer he
was like right you've never seen that
level of competitiveness and how like
how that dude could dominate we've never
seen but there's people I realize
they're like oh no I've seen highlights
and I'm like no you don't get it like
you don't get how dominant he was Jordan
yeah Jordan like yeah if you saw Jordan
dominant it was the craziest ever the
first time I saw Jordan fly from the
foul line through the air and slam dunk
a ball I'm ever thinking hat
how does a person how does a person even
do that with their body
yeah chief he literally flew
the air and slam dunk this ball and I'm
not exaggerating where it was like
basically where the foul line was he
[ __ ] went flying took an extra favor
Joella one favor yeah you put on the top
ten dunks by Julius Erving oh just one
second Jordan well that'll break because
before LeBron there was yeah Jordan yeah
for Jordan there was a guy from Long
Island Julia sure sure and he used to
kill one team the best dunks of all time
were done by him against the Lakers here
guys this isn't this isn't well this is
a regular one yeah okay this is nothing
okay oh that this is against Luke watch
this one one-handed that's just superb
that's superb watch this boom and bam
over again seven foot four and he's six
foot six he is against look at this BAM
okay my favorite was Darryl Dawkins over
a hooker Bryce's go cook with coke from
the top of refrigerator with his back
run this back dog he was oh he was gonna
call my podcast but he died no no that's
against bill walk look at this one
I guess my god that was this guy that's
beautiful
the elevation man the problem is that's
what everybody wants to see you don't
want to see all the [ __ ] leading up to
the yeah it's like when I watch them all
this was traumatic
hurry up against the Mormon trail blazes
look at the baguettes Bill Walton no one
kept calling for a foul look at them
bill worn all this [ __ ] look at them
look a [ __ ] you're gonna be the loss
but I'm slamming right in your [ __ ]
face see but one was called for a foul
you know what I feel like if you have a
dishonorable claim and a foul if you're
doing something like those soccer
players do sometimes yeah this one you
should lose points look at this one Joe
Rogan is the one I bet I won I had the
sixes in Philly
is Michael Cooper is [ __ ] he magic bean
I was there they gave you a theory
hamburgers I was down to him fly look at
him he was never getting appointed elfia
okay now go to ten greatest Michael
Jordan dunks oh my god and prepare
yourself for a [ __ ] Avatar movie yet
on the toilet get on the toilet right
now is the ball boy for the nets and you
find out a lot about basketball players
first of all do you know basketball
players throw away their sneakers after
every game it's crazy they lot of them
do so he would take the sneakers and
sell him on them on the before eBay he
would take the net sneakers his Selim
look at this crazy [ __ ] come on man that
looked like somebody pressed controls
and then a body did that he has some
spectacular airtime oh man look at this
he just flies in there man I wonder
what's like the record distance I know I
said from the free-throw line but what's
like the record distance if someone's
ever dunk from you know who's a Palicki
who's way crazier 82 the dunker though
18 18 it's 15 from the free throw and
it's 18 from the top of the key
someone a ton 20 Julius Erving oh my all
the time in the things what that not
David Thompson he's shaking his head
Jamie sake saying no boy that's about as
far as anyone's done the free-throw
think maybe 50 think yeah that's still
insane to say now it's done like a foot
or two behind it now have you ever seen
Vince Carter's dunks because that dude
is 40 let's well indeed let's enjoy
these first yeah yeah these are amazing
go to Vince Carter but let's enjoy these
for a moment cuz these respect I mean
Jordan was just some weather for Hannah
it's AB it's a beautiful thing another
planet Tom Segura
I'm watching 3430 yeah and I want to
call Joe Rogan and call him because I
know he's not that sport like the one
about Detroit when they beat him up
really mess yeah he decided to lift
weights
trying to get on that yeah he said this
ain't ever gonna happen
look at this donkey was when he was like
done what Joe Rogan oh yeah he's way
look at the way he'll is yeah because
then when he went and got on really
lifted against the Detroit Pistons but
Joe Rogan as a basketball enthusiast and
I called Dahmer ever there's only one
the greatest dunk of all time and
because he jumped over a [ __ ]
who did that this car that's him talking
over and until you a man fly Drexler oh
yeah I guess Louisville 1981 put it on
the Wizards a dunk and Houston was
called phi slamma jamma because that's
all they did was dunk there's a few
athletes that I feel like even from our
era you could bring two today and they
would be super successful like Marvin
Hagler is one of them I'm so ready boom
no ice not the ones on that that's not
the one no there's a few athletes that I
think you could take today and they
would be super successful like for sure
Julius Erving for sure Michael Jordan
for sure for sure yeah Johnson for sure
no matter what like bring him into this
era they'll be successful in almost any
yeah I'll never forget I was in a bobble
who died
Vince Carter dude I was at a bar one
night and there was a Cuban dude and he
was passed out like this Joe Rogan can
you find the video Joey of the dude they
he jumped over the dude look at this
[ __ ] what's this this is Vince Carter he
rubbed his nuts on that dudes head watch
that again watch this he rubbed his nuts
on that detail yeah it's incredible
he went over that dudes head just dude
still dunk like he's 40 that's insane
that's an athlete when we were in high
school he was in high school for a
minute
close to us he jumped over that guy they
would show his high school highlights on
local news like it was they would come
like an NBA game dude look at look I
know it's he's rubbing his dick on that
guy's ear watch
well he's [ __ ] as much [ __ ] his
[ __ ] face right he's mine [ __ ] him
directly through the ear oh and then
slams that that's insane yeah no Roy
Jones jr. was like that Roy Jones jr. in
his prime had some athleticism that
didn't even make sense he was able to
land a lead left hook instead of a jab
where a lot of guys shot in a jab Roy
Jones jr. he like most of the time led
with a lead left hook whoa Jesus that
guy can fly yeah you know I could REM
dunk that's the arm and rim dunk ladies
and gentlemen so much more difficult to
the right think about you gotta worry
about breaking david thompson had a
forty eight jump vertical way inch I
think about that that was thirty years
ago
I can't imagine the kind of vertical
jumps college players they had to be up
to 60 55 inches those defensive backs
Michael Irvin Michael Irvin could jump
four feet in the air yeah that's how he
became like 1 1 a.m. he's a freak the
kitchen with giants with the blond hair
now that lowdown back I see him my Jake
glaze his plate ain't no bigger than you
though
Odell Beckham big lasers got a hell of a
gym huh I saw Stallone was working out
there with Chuck Liddell's like what
kind of crazy gym you have you know see
that football players and whiners all
day long training what's it called again
something bottom performance unbreakable
I'm great breakable
yeah the owner is your move man good
move on his part he was a linebacker
from Chicago that's a that's a smart
move you know be a part of some sort of
a cool strength look at that dog this is
an injury on hand well athletes are
always getting better right if you go
back to baseball from the 1950s and then
go to baseball in 2017
you're seen better and better athletes
you're seeing people that are just
faster smarter trained better you know
use better nutrition they're optimizing
themselves the best they can the
question is like I wonder like
genetically was half
I wonder if like people genetically are
getting bigger and faster I wonder if
it's like a little slight uptick that
will one day maybe 20 years now 30 years
from now register in a big way
because you got a wonder with all these
people competing in CrossFit and all the
strength and conditioning stuff people's
bodies might start literally thinking
they have to work harder again
I have to get stronger and bigger again
people might get bigger this is my
terrible understanding of genetics as
apply I'm sold on it based on that alone
did I spit in a cup dog I'm waiting I
got another three weeks I spit in a cup
to see who I'm related to do you see
that thing about all those white races
what found out they were black people in
their pasts credit the test for that
reason yeah you know who you could talk
[ __ ] about cuz if you find out like I
could talk [ __ ] about Italians sure cuz
I'm mostly Italian yeah you know so most
people wouldn't consider a bad thing
well you black Sicilians got raped by
the Moors and then the more and then the
Sicilians one night on the night of the
Vespers and 1600 got up and they cut
their dicks off and shoved them in their
[ __ ] mouth what that's why you can't
talk about rape in front of most
Sicilians neither the Vespas is an old
Sicilian tradition ago that's why those
Sicilians are good with knives crazy now
it's Sicilians are good with knives they
tell you keep them at arm's distance but
with old Sicilians don't [ __ ] with them
cuz they got those knives they're good
with those knives and [ __ ] it's crazy
Cubans my sister's dark skin and then I
look at my cousin who's my skin and his
sister the singer is dark-skinned yeah
so I know there's some African [ __ ] in
my [ __ ] blood it's Cuba who's um
what's the band's name ex Alfonso Teddy
aqui aqui
what is that band the band they're in
the next Alfonso is that it his name is
Aki and her name is Emma amazing band
really dude they're really good but they
only [ __ ] - Rhea so
yeah here it is exhale font so back to
my mail cut give me some give me some
volume on this [ __ ] they're really good
dude I mean no [ __ ] I listen to this
on my way to the comedy store all the
time how you pumped up because I don't
know what the [ __ ] they're saying so
just for me it just feels good it's like
celebratory and I get into my own head
thinking about my material and I get
pumped up listen to this one night you
sent me a video you looking at you were
listening to something else like Italian
music I always do that yeah I always
listen to language that I don't
understand so you don't think about the
words yeah I don't think about the words
at all see this isn't I don't understand
what this is and there's there's
ignorance in it but there's also freedom
so the freedom is that I can hear the
beautiful sound of his voice and not
have any context to it no no like
whatever his messages or anything and I
can have it in the background and 100%
concentrate on what I'm trying to do
yeah and just enjoy it yeah instrument
yeah like if you like listening to a
shooting star by bad company you know
Johnny was a school boy when I heard his
first Beatles song that's gonna change
the way you feel yeah like you hear
about that you're writing about a
certain thing you're not gonna build the
concentrate on your subject sure I'm
gonna do I think it was from there it
didn't take him long and when I was in
high school everybody wanted to be that
guy everybody wanted to be that bright
star that burnt out and didn't fade away
and it's like man we lost Johnny I just
get love when he goes I love when he
goes don't you know [ __ ] tremendous
it's a great [ __ ] he's a male yeah I
look at his system you scroll down Shawn
my sister so my whole family's like this
where the male is light-skinned but my
sister is dark-skinned I just said [ __ ]
it I got it there's some other kids sent
me paperwork that I was related to some
italian navy guy called Luis Diaz from
ninth to from 1832 so I said enough with
this [ __ ]
let me just spit in the car plus it also
tells you where your genetics died and
where you might die of well you might
get cancer of you might have car
vascular disease it tells you you're
susceptible if my family did a family
reunion in 2000 and they hired this like
genealogy expert and they thought like
this would be like the big culmination
on Saturday ooh
to present a family history to everybody
in the family it's like who 30 40 people
there this weekend no no this was in the
year 2000 and then that guy started
telling us about this our first guy that
came over from Spain and then where he
landed in like 1721 I was pretty cool
and then he was just like he was a real
piece of [ __ ] and like he killed
somebody and he went to he you know went
to prison and then he was stealing for
people and when he died he left 60
slaves to this person everybody was like
well that fools me like there's Diaz's
or a Cuban yeah and then there's the
Diaz brothers to the Mexican right yeah
okay so that means our relatives came
from Spain well went to an island yeah
and the other one went to Mexico through
some way I look at those Diaz brothers
and I go I got it this guy were both
were two or three of us [ __ ] hmm
there's got to be some type of blood
that we share cause we're not all there
but there's there's also Diaz in Puerto
Rico right yes and that's a different
kind of Diaz than the Mexican Diaz too
you know yes it's you know it's really
interesting once you hear enough Spanish
and you hear the difference between like
like being friends with you and
listening to a lot of Cuban people talk
yeah like Cuban people have like a very
certain rhythm and then Puerto Ricans
have like a different kind of rhythm and
Mexicans have their own rhythm all
diligence yeah and the funny thing about
hanging out with Tom is people look at
him and he looks like a broski from like
Wisconsin or something they don't
realize he speaks fluent Spanish so
people will talk [ __ ] in Spanish in
front of you all the time about me
sometimes yeah all the time
they would never guess what what happens
when you drop it on them it's it depends
man like sometimes you get they like
think you can see the shame wash over
them they say some ruse at the end I'll
say like have a nice day
anything yeah I know I got your app you
have a great day rusty they could
possibly and they're like and then bones
no sometimes they there's like a laugh
sometimes you know I've had it go even I
remember in high school my cousin came
from Peru and we went into it was the
reverse we went into a what is it GNC
yeah we were like 14 and I go in Spanish
because he's visiting I tell him this
place is easy to steal from and then I
don't realize that the the lady working
at the store was banished yeah oh so
instead of she just let us kind of look
around and then and then she started
speaking to us in Spanish we were like
oh yes we thought we were speaking to
some crazy code you know like this isn't
[ __ ] you know a Farsi that you're
gonna run into a lot it was Spanish but
it happens all the time in yeah so I
also realized that I don't know what
happens to you because I don't look
Spanish a lot of times spanish-speaking
people don't want me to speak Spanish to
them was I if they're here they're
they're not appreciating that you're not
letting make it letting them show you
that they can speak English a lot of
times that's interesting because
Americans wouldn't give a [ __ ] if you
were over in like Italy and so we're
talking English yeah and you had like
one of those translators you're trying
to like yo soy you try to talk to him
and he just start saying isn't a problem
I speak perfect fluent English oh yeah
oh thank God it's just talking here it's
different though you'd never be like oh
let me struggle sometimes it's somebody
that I speak way better Spanish then
they speak English really still insist
on keeping it English that's rough it
gives them a like with me they look at
me for a minute and then once I start
going off yeah like those hello Oh walk
talk anybody could say those yeah it's
when they ask me how's your day going
like when somebody's Spanish system it
gets up my sound oh I always say if I
hello long question we'll see been
compiling yeah and they look at me I
tell him I'm here fighting with these
[ __ ] white people on a day life and
they look at me and go okay he's okay
but the guy at the weed store at cush
Martin yeah
they used to be a little security guard
and I didn't say nothing to him he never
looked at my name he would just look at
Joey or some and he would go right that
good Italian or he the fat Italian
had I let him roll for like eight times
and one day I said oh yeah you don't you
know look at that photographer Dorothea
no more oh [ __ ] Tommy or puta and his
face turn pal like he had a gun and
everything that he got Pam cuz I said
never disrespect me and I'll never
disrespect you you son of a [ __ ] he
just turned pale oh we clear these they
come here I'm gonna get you discounts on
weed up in the valley sure sure because
he lived in Hollywood at the time but I
would catch people but it's really weird
yes some people don't some people don't
some people are cool dude you ain't seen
somebody kill until you seen Joey Diaz
do half Spanish half English in Miami
and the improv I bet in 2004 2003 2004
when that place was crazy yeah that's
crazy
sure I could go off have really fun in
Spanish people get great when I imitate
as the people you know I grew up around
the Cuban guys I grew up around were
very funny I was telling a friend of
mine yeah that was bartending in high
school I had to quit high school in bar
ten there was his bookie I hung out
their name was our Nardo and he didn't
speak no English I used to talk to him
he was a Cuban dude built me had a big
big gut and one day he was sitting in a
chair like this and my buddy was joke
and he's telling him about y'all quoting
your body and my he goes I had a go my
friend goes what he gonna go home we
didn't speak Spanish on Nardo it was
really awful yes and my friend goes what
are you talking about no fear nor door
was sitting in a bar chair that didn't
go back and he just started going oh
when I go home now forget it
they started making believe like he was
jerking off and he would make the noises
I and everything this bars looking at
him his dick hey now but he's going I I
and when he would come he would pop back
in his chair go ba ba ba ba the whole
[ __ ] bar
and then he would sit back you know oh
oh you'll it being si Baja his father he
would play out the whole thing the
people running and you're very [ __ ]
life today that put you in jail I uh a
few of you did that today have you
leaned back in the bar and started
jerking off into the sky oh my god did
put you in jail
that's sexual assault just to do the
impersonation I'm sure didn't Jim
Morrison get in trouble for that he
pulled his dick out his dick out yeah
yeah famous concert but I thought that
it during mr. mojo risin he would make
believe he was whacking off and he got
arrested I think our boy who got
arrested the comedian for doing
something on stage like a sexual
something which guy the original gun
Lenny Lenny did I think he just got
arrested for talking I don't think he
would ever pull his dick out I think
that no no I'm not same point dick I
mean like doing the motion oh maybe we
definitely are prosecuted for profanity
was this a yeah Jim Morrison's many of
the nearly 12,000 youth said they found
the bearded singer's exhibition
disgusting including included in the
audience where hundreds of unsorted
junior and senior high school girls
Morrison appeared to masturbate in full
view of the audience screamed
obscenities and exposed himself he also
got violent slugged several in
parentheses concert promoters and threw
one of them off the stage before he
himself was hurled into the crowd with
his dick hanging out Wow interesting
he says to this day Morrison's bandmates
deny this version of events as guitarist
Robby Krieger explained the spinner they
were complaining about Jim whipping it
out on stage which he didn't do
500 photos were entered as evidence the
trial and not one of them showed
anything of the sort
regardless after rejecting a plea
bargain the singer was found guilty of
misdemeanor counts of indecent exposure
and open profanity and sensin sentenced
to prison time and a fine the case was
on appeal at the time of his death
July 3rd 1971 Wow interesting in
clemency board in 2010 voted to pardon
the singer more than 40 years later who
the [ __ ] knows would happen if they
don't have a picture his dick out I
thought they had a picture of it if they
don't have a picture his dick out
somebody could have yelled his dicks out
which is just like yelling fire in a
crowded building he whole thing at the
end of hell a woman mr. mojo risin yeah
right and he would make believe right
[Music]
yeah yeah maybe to them it looks like
masturbation to him it looks like he was
playing like an air guitar yeah he
pretended to jerk off yeah maybe you not
allowed to do that back then really I
would deny like a good 40 percent of all
of our material it's a lot of it I told
you you can't fake jerk off on stage a
boy
Who am I gonna make this myth work
there's a couple specials that are gone
entirely [ __ ] that was one of my best
ones yeah [ __ ] you need to edit out all
the stroking it parts you'd be like oh
so limited in my game damn it I had to
get the [ __ ] out of here what the [ __ ]
Joey Diaz it's only three and a half
hours into the show it's Jesus I gotta
pick the baby up listen this is one of
my favorite times ever oh my god no I'm
gonna have to review it to find out what
the [ __ ] you said that made me laugh
taught I literally couldn't breathe but
to everybody that's been on the show
thank you thank you to everybody
listening thank you thanks to all
everybody from top to bottom
I love the [ __ ] out of you people more
to come and Tom Segura and christina
pazsitzky is your mom's house one of the
best podcasts on the Internet of course
Church what's happening now Lisa at the
Flying Jew and the great Joey cocoa Diaz
available on everywhere and that's it
thanks we'll see you more Hey
are ready to go for our law is it that
pedalin cry everything tonight oh all
right we love you guys
thank you love
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]